I told my wife when I got with her I
said look I'll do anything for you
except one thing I will not give up on
that dream if I got to surrender my
dream I'd rather be alone because if I
abandon my dream I'll abandon you I
truly believe that I see so many people
man they give up their dream for the
wife they give up their dream for the
husband and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and they give up their dream again
because of the kids and I said the day
we have kids we cannot blame the kids
for not going after our potential and
our dreams if we ever have kids when we
were getting together and she wasn't
ready to have kids she wasn't even ready
for me so I knew she was the right
person for me and I'm like look I'll
give you anything monogamy I'll never
cheat on you I'll never Jack around on
you I'll take care of you I'll provide
you with a life that you can only dream
of this was 12 years ago I mean this is
way before Grant really hit full Grant
and which she's really added to and made
it easier but I said look if I got to be
less than who I'm meant to be to be with
you can't give you that I said I got
books in me I'm going to do the biggest
events in the world I'm gonna do a TV
show I will be known by millions if not
billions of people and I will leave a
legacy that has been with me before I
ever met you
and I'm not giving that because then I
give that up I'll give you up hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Grant
Cardone enjoy
I think it's priorities just I think
it's you know watching my dad die and
and he did everything right everything
he worked hard saved his money paid his
debts off
respected his name he was respected in
the community he did everything right
and when he died my mom had to my mom
had to start hustling and shuffling and
scared and she was he did everything
right and it didn't work so when I saw
that when I saw my dad was my mom was
having to sell my dad's Dream House a
week after he died I'm like something's
wrong with the game he's playing so I've
been challenging the game the whole time
like oh my dad was taught he was taught
the wrong rules
and he played by the rules and it still
didn't get him out it's the middle class
mythology you know it's it's the idea
that I'm gonna have just enough so since
then I've been challenged really looking
at everything that masses of people
believe in family first you know this
people throw that around all the time
I'm blessed everybody says they're
blessed yeah but you know go Prove It Go
prove we're all blessed go prove it so
these are some things that I just like
like the dream thing I'm like is family
first or was my dream first well in my
case my dream was before my family I
hear people all the time complain about
their job they don't want to have a job
I'm like man you have to love your job
if you don't love your job how are you
going to go start a business and have
people that work for you that don't hate
their job
it's a gift to be able to have a job
like if you can smile I really believe
this if I can smile throughout my life
even when I'm eating
like yeah okay what else you got you
know
I was telling Elena she was down there
boxing this morning and with Javier and
her cooks are getting awesome
and she had this look on her face right
I said look you gotta smile when you do
that kick you gotta smile when you punch
you got to smile when you get punched
because when you can smile when you're
eating taking a punch
when things are not going well when
you're terrified and you can keep
smiling through it I think I think
Roosevelt said or maybe it was Churchill
said hey look when you're going through
hell skip
move run
okay and have a smile on your face like
it doesn't bother you
and and you become dangerous to other
people when you can eat you're humble
enough to say yeah okay I'll do the
dishes okay I'll sweep the floors the
first thing I might want to do before I
start planning new stuff
take some of the stuff out of my garden
I need to make some space
I need to make some space I need to
remove the weeds I need to mulch the
ground I need to take something out I
need to dig in remove stuff okay get the
soil
uh ready for new plants and new trees
and a lot of times in fact every time in
my life
[Music]
for me to get
for me to get from this place right here
where I am I'm parked right now
for me to get from here to there I have
to leave here
that is the number one rule of success
I have to give up something
and for me I've given up drugs I've
given up friends I gave up a girlfriend
that I was like madly madly in love with
crushed me for years I've done that two
of those
they weren't right for me I just weren't
the right people for me I was in love
but
whatever chemistry
it diluted my power
I've given up
a house in Houston Texas where I had
friends and family I gave up a house in
La Jolla that I absolutely love still
love today still missed that house today
20 years I've been out of that house
miss it almost every day
had to give it up though to become this
guy
gave up a house Elena and and I gave up
a house in Los Angeles magnificent
magnificent house
you know I would flip my house where I
lived today I would flip it off to go
live back in that house today
the sacrifices people pay every day
every day I still go to work today I
give up my free time to go to work
because I got 107 employees
that depend on me
for a paycheck
for inspiration
my company feels it when I'm not there I
know they feel it
Johnny the camera guy starts missing
you know the other guys start missing me
I got a great team too my team holds
everything together but
even when you're the the king you were
you you're the man the boss you're the
you're the the queen of the of the
empire
still working people you still got to
give up your freedom and your right to
do whatever you want this is the secret
of the successful people this is what
I've committed my life to doing I told
my mom when I was 16 years old one day
one day I'm going to be successful one
day one day I'm gonna be successful and
one day I'm gonna help a lot of people I
always say this pay the price today so
you can pay any price in the future pay
the price now okay pay the price my
buddies were traveling seeing the world
and I didn't have any of those
experiences
I've had people tell me hey you Market
too much
you Market too aggressively
take me off your list
my office tells me we hit the list too
much I'm like what's a list for
hit the list
that's what it's for there's a 888
billion people on planet Earth
look I've been ridiculed by my peers my
customers and by competition I've been
judged for working too much wanting too
much being too colorful being
inappropriate insensitive and too out
there
I'm trying to figure it out I've been
threatened I've been sued I've been
betrayed by friends I've been ripped off
and I've been copied
30 years 30 years 18 hour days not eight
hour days not 10 hour days not 12 hour
days 18 hour days
I've been married 15 years to Elena not
one time has she ever said you work too
much not one time
[Applause]
she has never said to me what are you
doing getting home so late she knows
what I'm doing
I'm closing deals
I'm taking care of my family I'm trying
to get to 10x levels it's been 30 years
30 years it's probably going to be 30
years for you too doubt uncertainty
insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
gonna be 30 years of it are you willing
to pay the price
are you willing to pay the price
anybody thinks
you're going to be successful
at the stress rice
[Music]
this concept of work
that the wealthy don't work hard I hear
this constantly you know rich people
don't work hard you know rich people
rich people work smart
that that you got to be kidding right
rich people take all the vacations it's
not true rich people don't take all the
vacation the vacation industry the
vacation industry literally is built off
the middle class not the wealthy
now you might not like this concept but
I'm going to tell you the truth this is
a report that just recently came out
okay one of the most controversial
issues surrounding inequality is work
effort this is a concept of why do the
rich get richer and those people that
don't have or don't have enough keep
sliding down the scale and that's what I
do in these Grant rants is I'm talking
to the middle class about look do you
see it disappearing it's going away
okay the middle class is getting erased
I came from the middle class and I see
what's happening to it what we used 20
or 30 years ago or 40 years ago to build
a middle class is not working for us
today for instance work hard okay you
see there's this concept that no you
don't need to work hard you just need to
work smart if you work smart get the
right connections you'll get rich that's
not true this is what it says in this in
this article I found this in the wealth
report do the wealthy work harder than
the rest you might want to Google it a
new study offers evidence that higher
education and therefore higher earning
okay Americans do indeed spend more time
working and less time on Leisure than
poorer income groups okay it's been
validated in this study it says in fact
while incoming inequality inequality may
be growing which it is Leisure
inequality time spent on enjoyment okay
time spent on enjoyment is a growing in
a mirror image what is that saying
people that are actually making less
money and less wealth are actually
spending more time in Leisure why
because I miss you were taught a myth
you were taught this concept of enjoy my
life you know I gotta enjoy my life I
need to enjoy the day the wealthy don't
think like that I'm telling you the most
successful people don't think about
enjoying life I gotta enjoy they think
about luxury man they think about the
Big Bang they think about the big big
win not the little
two-day vacation
what they do is they'll suffer their
whole life so they can go go on vacation
later when there's wealth for two and
three months at a time you get it work
hard okay work hard it is a myth that
you're not going to work hard I'm
working harder today than I ever have in
my life
most people only work hard enough
that they're always working you get it
most people only work so hard that they
feel like they're always slaves remember
this anytime you feel like a slave
you've let somebody else be your master
do you know what I'm talking about junk
people buy junk people go on vacations
people waste time and they don't have
any money don't let that be you whoever
is most certain wins the sales game okay
you want to write this down it is not
about trust it is about certainty
whoever is most certain wins the sales
game
certainty wins the sales game if he's
certain he's not going to do it he ain't
going to do it if I'm certain he is
going to do it certainly wins the game
whoever's most certain wins the game
Elena was less certain about marrying me
than I was certain about her marrying me
had nothing to do with love
okay you don't need love to close the
deal
you need certainty
half of the people they've done business
with me said they would never do
business with me half the people that
followed me today did not like me when
they first saw me one of the number one
comments we get is man the first time I
saw one of your videos I hated your guys
I keep showing up they changed their
mind how many of you know they're saying
you can never change a bad first
impression how many know they're saying
it's completely not true some of my best
customers have come from Bad First
Impressions I can't control a first
impression some of you came in the room
and didn't like me today when you walked
in here nothing to do with me it's about
you having a bad day okay now let me
flip the page and give you a little
certainty you see how you wrote it down
this is how I would write it down number
one you greet the customer number two
you qualify the customer you greet hey
that's how long our greeting takes by
the way if you spend more than two
seconds on a greeting Thomas great to
have you here appreciate you coming
that's it it's not about the weather
it's not about politics people spend so
much time in the greeting let's build
rapport Rapport is in the second step in
the qualification
how can I help your company make him
more money that's what he said I need to
remember that the qualification process
is designed to figure out what to show
him and how to close it this is a report
building step I'm taking interest in why
he's here why do people buy things
solve a problem that's the only reason
anybody on the planet ever buys any
product
to solve a problem demonstrate the
product make a proposal close follow-up
those are six steps what are they great
qualify demonstrate propose close
follow-up did I miss anything everybody
try this great
number one great number one green number
two qualify
three demonstrate
four make a proposal
make a proposal make a proposal
number five close the deal
follow up
That's it man look if you can't remember
them you can't do them you should write
this down every day this year is either
going to be better for me
or it's going to be worse for me my
marriage is either going to get better
this year or it's going to get worse my
money's going to get better it's going
to get worse my health is going to get
better my health is going to get worse
what I do today will determine whether
it's going to be better or whether it's
going to be worse it will not be up to
trump it will not be up to the Democrats
it will not be up to to something that
happens in Iran it won't be up to the
stock market it's up to you first get
rid of the little think
and the old ideas
and the middle class mentality
I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna save some
money I'm gonna put it in the bank I'm
gonna give it to the Man
what's the bank do the bank doesn't even
keep your money
they hate money
cash is
it's trash
is garbage it's pieces the garbage paper
it is only useful when it is used if
you're taking notes
they didn't teach you this in school
this should have been taught basic fifth
grade sixth grade not in not when in
high school or college cash this is a
piece of paper okay it is a piece of
paper it's worthless this is a piece of
paper this actually has more value this
piece of paper right here has more value
than this piece of paper right here why
because one person has this piece of
paper
two thousand people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
how many of you were taught to say stuff
how many of you got sticky notes and you
save them
you write you write like 17 different
things on one sticky note
I don't I don't want to use the whole
pad
I'm gonna make this I'm gonna make this
sticky pad last the rest of my life
okay you got to get rid of the little
thing folks this little think is killing
you let's find out if you got the little
think
how many believe success is a mind game
dude this starts right here you got to
fix this you got to get rid of let's
find out if you've been affected
okay I want you to look at your
refrigerator at home
what's in it
water
nothing's in it it's empty
it's very frugal of you
let's buy a refrigerator keep it empty
okay
huh
leftovers what kind of leftovers
what do you got in there
a week old salad he opens the
refrigerator maybe tomorrow
I don't want to throw it away
why
because his mother taught him that eat
all your food eat all your food eat all
your food how many of you are brought up
like this three times a day eat it all
your family's important your dreams are
important these are the things that need
to be first on your mind every day
not last it's either the first
first last my dreams are first every day
then my wife then my kids
I could take care of my wife and my kids
now would you agree I abandoned this
this is the fuel for who I am I abandon
this dream
and then I end up I can't take care of
them
and then I'm gonna tell them what
it's all right that you didn't win
no it's not all right if you don't win
you need to win how many of you need to
win more
okay if you don't control your
environment folks somebody else is going
to control your environment you guys
that run teams and run organizations if
you do not control your environment
someone else will control your
environment you are being controlled in
your environment right now CNBC CNN
MSNBC the parents the kids the Twitter
the Facebook the YouTube the Google the
Snapchats or your environment your
friends and your relatives your uncles
your aunts the garbage dump called
planet Earth that you live on is mostly
broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with me
when I was 45 years old I'm like I'm
going to control my environment I'm
going to take every penny I have all the
energy I have all the resources I have
and I'm going to improve you if I got to
go broke in the process because I'm
already broke look if you're not
fulfilled to your if you're not reaching
your full potential every day you're
broke right now spiritually broke you
guys that are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I had the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I had the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day
kick start your day get going in your
day to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I
started building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that I can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when I go into
this meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
never give up on your financial goals
until you achieve your financial goals
there's people in this room folks that
are going to be worth billions of
dollars
there's a billionaire in this room right
now I'll guarantee you could be two or
three up
billionaires in the making right here
okay questioning who's it going to be
now if somebody in this room how many
believe this is somebody in this room
made a decision I'm going to put
together a billion dollars how many
believe that's possible
everybody in the room believes it's
possible you might not think it's
possible for you but you know it's
possible which means what the money's
available
would you would you do good things with
that billion dollars
okay you know that about yourself you
don't know about the guy sitting next to
you
you know that about yourself
so you know somebody could do it and you
know if you did it you do good things
with it right
so go do it man because the money's out
there there's plenty of it and I grew up
with a little uh five uh four foot 11 uh
Italian lady that knew nothing about
money she just knew hold on clip coupons
save your money how many were brought up
like that Penny saved is
and he earned save for a
see you were brought up the same way I
was eat all your
eat all your food if you don't eat it
all save it put it in the refrigerator
right some of you got you got food in
your refrigerator right now three and
four five days old
you have you have no intention of eating
it some of you got you got like an
eighth of a bagel left from five days
ago
right now you're like it's in there
right now you got you got you got ice
cream in your in your freezer that's
like six months old
it's expired twice
it's got that much frost on it but you
got one bite left
I know it's still good you tell your
kids this too you pass on the same boat
your kids eat all your food eat all your
food eat all your food and then you
wonder why we got obesity problems in
America
we live in a country that's rich and the
people have scarcity in their minds
success comes with this okay and does
not the higher you go up the tree the
more people are going to be like look at
him he's going to fall they want you to
fall they want to take you down okay
they want to hurt you but most
importantly they're trying to get
attention for their own brand or name
and they have nothing to create for
themselves
if they can't create anything what they
do is they hate okay it's like hate is
the opposite of create you can't create
and hate at the same time they did this
to Jesus they did it to Gandhi they did
it to Oprah they did it to Obama they
did it to Trump okay if you're gonna
blow if you're gonna get big if you're
gonna service the world help the world
become a charitable a source if you're
going to disrupt anything look what they
do to Elon Musk the entire automotive
industry and Biden wouldn't invite him
to an automotive conference where
they're discussing electric cars how's
that even possible every great person
that's ever walked on planet Earth male
or female younger old
has been hated on has been click baited
dragged criticized ridiculed dismissed
called
blah blah blah so this is what haters do
okay haters can't create so they hate
so number one you gotta understand that
this is part of success it comes with
everything else the success comes with
it comes with the money the toys the
winning the victories the happiness the
the celebrations uh what also comes with
success is this the criticizer and a
hater okay it's like building a house
you build a house you're going to end up
with the termites
you have a baby you're gonna end up with
poop
everything comes with a liability okay
so don't don't take it personal that
people hate on you take it as a
compliment I know it's hard
uh number one understand it's coming
number two do not respond directly to
these people
there's no reason to use their name
there's no reason to support them
there's no reason to honor them respond
to them
it doesn't matter dude they're not doing
anything they will I know that 10 years
from now they won't be where they they
won't be anywhere they will not have
done anything they will be off using or
dragging somebody else's name and I'm
gonna create my Empire
so go out create your success
do the things you got to do stay focused
on prospering we send out 40 million
dollars this year in Cardone Capital
distributions 40 million
everybody that drags my name combined
times 10 and times 10 lifetimes will not
generate for themselves that much money
much less give it back to their
investors that's in one year I've done
that I'm sorry that's in seven months
and I've done that we've done a billion
1.2 billion dollars in sales over the
internet
you you can put every click baiter
together in the same room and give them
a thousand lifetimes they won't produce
that much because you cannot produce and
create when you hate it's not possible
you just cannot be
you can't come up with Solutions you
can't make the world a better place
where you're hating on any one object
okay so when I when I literally put my
attention on negativity on one object
how can I create something good over
here it's not possible so don't be
distracted by the distracted
uh the third thing okay you have to
double down on your prosperity and your
success you got to keep expanding what
they hope to do is to contract you
don't contract extrovert keep extroverty
keep creating on the things you're doing
let let those let that that
detraction become an inspiration for
your creation for your continued
creation I remember hearing Elon Musk
say uh something about
um
somebody asked him what do you say about
your uh the people that say you can't do
this and he looked at him the
interviewer and says we did this
and that is really really important go
out and change the world go out and
serve as your customers service the
world that you want to service do the
things you want to do use the hate as an
inspiration to actually validate your
creation and to do what you're inspired
to do don't let it stop you don't let it
distract you don't let it introvert you
creating one is part of the game it's
part of the game
it's like anything else okay with every
asset every creation of every asset
comes some liability they're termites
freaking rats
they will never create anything for
themselves and their family that's
valuable much less shared with their
customers
their merchants of chaos like the media
Fox and CNN these people that are
spreading fake news all around this is
the only thing they can produce
is on the backs of successful
people so go out and be successful
understand the haters are coming too use
it
use it don't do don't don't recommend
them recognize them talk about them
talk about what you're doing double down
on it 10x on it use it to inspire you to
create more success for yourself and
your family move on and then last thing
is handle your family and friends on it
okay I had a friend once send me
something he saw somebody wrote back in
2020 oh my God I read this I'm like bro
what's wrong with you
what kind of friend
would believe
information from some scumbag you don't
even know
that's not a friend okay and I put his I
put his ethics in art I said stop it
don't even ask me about it don't
challenge me about it don't question me
about it how dare you you're my friend a
friend will support
will support their friends and not
listen to the garbage
they will actually Overlook the defects
of the individual and look at the good
they're doing support them in the good
they're doing trust that they're going
to continue to do this that's what
friends do so don't worry about the
haters worry about the friends and
listen to the book from the haters God
bless be great the thing I like about
real estate is I don't need to believe
that it's there I get to see that it's
there
I don't need to believe that 95 is
occupied I can take the 100 units
and I'm somebody's going to show me 95
leases
I don't need to believe there's a pool I
can see the pool you understand now with
Wall Street bond market checking account
savings account 401ks IRAs I got to
believe
this is one of the biggest companies in
the world
3 trillion they're sitting at and they
pay .05
of a percent
half of one percent so when you look at
that and it's a piece of paper by the
way and that half a percent is fully tax
to you
fully taxed which means if you're in a
50 tax bracket that's .025
that's a quarter of one percent it will
take you four years to earn one percent
on your money it would take you eight
years to earn two percent you get the
math here you got a problem if it's just
a dividend you're trying to get but of
course it's not just a dividend you're
trying to make money on this stock in
the case of the real estate okay let's
say I put a million dollars in Apple
stock or a million dollars in Bitcoin
whatever the case is the target's a
million dollars I have my last million
dollars and I threw it in a deal it's a
million it's a hundred grand it's ten
thousand pick whatever number you want
and I'm looking for a double this has to
go from 174 to 348 to hit a double
how many believe it'll do it at some
point
probably will
now bitcoin's at 50 what is it that
47 000.
so for me to double my money there it's
got to go to 94 000. never been there
ever probably will go there one day if
these both of these get there within a
year I gotta pay 50 taxes on that on
that exchange everybody agree with that
somewhere around 50 47 something okay if
you're in California 63 I could take a
million dollars
me and a couple buddies we could buy
four million dollar piece of Real Estate
already I'm already at an advantage over
apple and Bitcoin
why what's my advantage over over those
two
one million is supported by four million
dollars worth of of assets
okay that produce cash flow
even if this thing goes down from three
million to 3.2 4 million down down to
three and a half million even if it was
less valuable next week I wouldn't sell
it by the way only got a million dollars
invested in it okay I still get cash
flow from that asset you understand this
asset can go down in value and the cash
flow could actually go up
okay in 2010 assets didn't trade they
didn't trade at all we talked about this
in our VIP lunch yesterday in in 2008
9-10 even 11 the assets would not move
but the cash flow kept getting better
so this million dollars buys four
million dollars what do I need to sell
this for this asset for
in order to double my money
that's all I got to do this this has got
to be sold for five million dollars
if this sells for only one million
dollars more than I bought it for
that's only need it to go up 25 percent
okay these two assets over here have to
go up 100 percent
for me to make the money I want to make
to get a double I got to get a hundred
percent to get a double in a real estate
deal
I only need that real estate to go up 25
nothing's really happened by the way in
these recessions nothing's really
changed it's just an illusion that
somehow oh my God there's no money now
now the the money's still there
nothing's really changed except
everybody's mindset everybody still has
to eat they still have to wear clothes
they still have to travel they still
want to have sex and procreate and have
fun and go to the movies and everybody
wants to do the same stuff you still got
8 billion people on the planet growing
every day the the thing is there's fewer
people going for it this is what I
always say man there's there's a an
abundance amount of money on planet
Earth and a shortage of people going
after it and this is the perfect time
this is it go all out bro this is it
because what happens if you 10x your
efforts for for just short periods of
time maybe six or eight or nine months
and start building out a new network of
people what happens is
people are going to back out
and you're gonna look up and you'll be
like there's only three or four of us on
the field
like there's only going to be a handful
of people playing the game everybody
else is just just oh I'm grateful you
know we're we're better off than the
pakistanians and the Palestinians in the
in the Cubans and the it's all you're
always comparing yourself to some third
world country that's not developed this
is what people do all the time by the
way okay uh there's some Village in
Africa where you know they don't have
running water I hear this story all the
time these people you ever been to
Africa we have food you know you don't
even know what you're talking about
you're comparing you could always find
somebody worse off to compare yourself
to when what you should be doing instead
looking up is setting an example for all
the people that are below you or side of
you they're suffering and say no man we
should be expanding and have prosperity
in all times especially in tough times
most people just simply have the wrong
target
most small businesses in America Break
Even or lose money because they have
their own Target they're just like I
just want to make 70 grand out of my
business I want to own my business I
want to be the boss the boss of what
you know and so so first thing we do is
fix the target what is the target this
reset is going to be create massive
opportunities this is where wealth is
created in very short periods of time
anybody can get this well because the
big money is going to sideline it has to
sideline because it's public
a little more complicated but they're
public so they have to be careful okay
and you don't you need to take risks
right now you know I remember when I was
a kid a man told me he's like Grant
patience is a virtue and I looked at him
and said are you trying to get a head
start on me
because that's what it sounds like that
reminds me of how many people say money
won't make you happy you know uh rich
people aren't happy look folks okay why
is this whole Rich topic so sensitive to
so many people why is it so many people
the moment you say Rich wealthy get rich
get wealthy the first thing that happens
everybody's like rich people they you
you get all this negativity around being
rich rich people aren't happy rich
people are dysfunctional rich people
rich people are greedy rich people are
selfish you've heard all that money
won't make you happy why all the disdain
why the hate why the criticism for the
wealthy I'm not talking about people
that inherited their money I'm talking
about people that worked from nothing
and created an Empire and created true
wealth that you can't possibly get rid
of in a lifetime people that will
actually create so much wealth that they
they'll leave it for generations to come
the duponts the Fords the carnegies bad
people
or did they do something really big look
when I talk about getting rich I'm
talking about you tapping into your full
potential not just financially but in
all areas of your life my family I'm
rich my company I'm rich my finances I'm
rich my bit my other businesses are rich
not just because they have money but
because they're rich in ideas rich in
great people rich in energy resources
and creativity man get rich man and if
you don't want to get rich please don't
blame other people that want to that's
the rant for the day how many times in
my life
I've I've woken up like like not sure
I think it started happening for me
uh years ago like like
probably around 12 or 13. I didn't know
what to do every day what's what's today
going to bring maybe it's after watching
so much TV and eating so much sugar you
know I think our diets definitely have a
lot to do with all that
but look I want to give you something
today about how to get out of the funk
the funky honk doc
when I by the time I was 25 this thing
went on from 12 to 25 at 25 years old I
was in so much depression every day I
was using drugs alcohol
I was self-medicating constantly
making bad decisions I lived in a 275
uh
uh I mean I just remember how much it
was it was 275 dollars a month and every
other month I couldn't make the bill the
payment I was late
today I live in this joint right here
live up on the 33rd floor of this place
and
a completely different life today than I
had then 25 I went to a treatment center
for 20 28 days for drug addiction I was
using drugs every day hated it
let me tell you something worse than
drugs is how you feel about yourself I
hated myself every time I did a drug
every time I smoked weed every time
every time I did
any drug the moment I put the pill in my
mouth the weed to my mouth something in
my nose I hated myself
I never felt good
about using drugs
and so
by the time I was 25 I had been using
drugs for
10 years but my problem started before
that
my problems didn't start with the drugs
it started with my inability to manage
this
light grade chronic depression
this for lack of better words this this
idea that I wasn't good enough this idea
that I didn't love myself you know that
that you know my my mom gave my mom quit
on me my mom told me hey don't come
around here anymore my twin brother
pretty much what's done with me
my sisters both knew that I was in
trouble and were like oh my God you know
we're gonna get a call on him today
the people I worked with the principal
at the high school I went to said I
couldn't couldn't win dog catcher
in my 11th and 12th grade told my mom
that
my student
my PE teacher said I would amount to
nothing I wrecked my car on my driver's
ed test I failed my driver's license
test I was fired from my first six jobs
wouldn't leave the sixth one dude I'm
telling you I was a loser
loser okay I'm telling you loser and I
didn't have to ask other people nobody
had to tell me I was a loser I knew I
was a loser
so look if you've ever been there I know
there's people watching this right now
maybe you don't even know who I am
you're like who's this dude talking
about himself you know
I've come from that where I was bankrupt
spiritually financially physically I
weighed 134 pounds that's 40 pounds less
than I weigh today
I was broken every way possible I didn't
have any money I was in debt
but worst the worst thing the worst of
the worst of the worst
was how I felt about myself
I got out of that treatment center and
the counselor said to me I think his
name was Philip I don't remember the guy
now I hated this guts then I still don't
think much of him he said to me God was
really confused
he was more confused than I was he said
now that I look back he said to me he
said to me he said hey if you leave here
if you leave here and you don't give up
you know because when you're there you
spill your guts tell them everything and
I told them I wanted to be rich and
famous and and help people and write
books and you know be known all over the
world he says if you don't give all
those ideas I think he called it
grandiosity if you don't give up all
these grandiose ideas of changing the
world
uh being rich being famous
if you don't change all those ideas
you'll never ever ever make it you'll
never stay what do you call it you'll
never stay dry and sober if you're
waking up today and you're not feeling
it I'm not talking about workouts either
whatever it is going to work making a
call
cleaning up something that you had to
clean up handling some problem that you
have and you're waking up feeling a
little depressed
cut it down
uh
you know what I'm talking about just
don't quite fill it
everybody expects me to be up all the
time thinks I'm supposed to you know be
Mr 10x Mr 100 every day
that is never the case
never
I don't have all the right answers
I just want you to know like
40 of the time I'm wrong maybe a little
wooden actually
even
I just gotta be right on the big things
you know
and one thing that
that
has helped me
whether it was writing a book and
finishing it
are starting my speaking career when I
did it 30 years old I was going door to
door
to businesses around America
for three million miles
go to City I was living in Houston at
the time
in Bel Air Texas and I'd fly to Salt
Lake City and I'd call on business
owners
I'd set a an event two weeks in advance
commit to the hotel fly to Salt Lake
City knew no one no one knew me I had no
name no books
there was no social media
and
I never felt like doing I was scared
again
had no clue what I was doing
didn't know who I was calling on
don't even know how much I believed in
what I was doing like I did believe in
it
but it was like
you know I didn't have any statistics or
facts or success stories
and
regardless of how I felt just like this
morning
regardless how much doubt there was or
uncertainty
uh
fear
no matter who you're watching or who
you're following
whether it's
political
person uh
a rapper movie star
teacher coach parents
I don't care how much in confidence they
put out how much athlete how much
confidence or
certainty that they push out push out
like like project
they wake up there's days they wake up
and they don't feel it they don't feel
it they don't they don't want to do it
they're uncertain
they're feeling some low-grade
depression whatever you want to call it
look I woke up like that this morning
when
got up family's not here this weekend
uh Elena's got the kids she's teaching
them how to shoot guns this weekend
and I'm here by myself so I'm waking up
this morning like I don't want to work
out I missed yesterday
I'm not feeling it
so what do you do
what do you guys do when you don't feel
it
so this is what I do I just get a little
closer
this is what I do I get a little closer
just like I did when I was 30 years old
starting my speaking career never
thought I'd be one of the top considered
one of the top
two or three speakers in the world when
I was 30 years old I wanted that
but I didn't know how I was going to get
to that
and what I did was when I was having to
fly to these cities Salt Lake City
Winnipeg Saskatoon Toronto uh Vancouver
Chicago New York like I had never even
been to these places I was literally
flying to cities for the first time in
my entire career didn't know the
language didn't know the the culture
didn't know how they they those little
changes and that happened between
Toronto and New York New York and
Chicago Chicago and Dallas and Dallas
and Salt Lake Salt Lake and L.A those
are all very very different markets and
different people and different thinking
I was terrified okay I'm doing this
today to tell you I was terrified I was
so scared most the time that it felt
like not fear it felt like depression
like I wanted to take the the sheets
just pull them over my head so what I
did
to conquer that to handle that
I literally would just get a little
closer
I'd give myself a little closer to the
action like this morning I just got
close to the gym I actually went and
walked by the pool I have a pool in the
same spot that we have a gym on the
second floor here and I walked out there
and as I passed the gym there was nobody
in here I'm like okay there's nobody in
here to sign I'm gonna go in there and
work out okay so number one just try
getting a little closer to the action
hope that helps you just get a little
closer you don't have to commit to doing
it completely just get closer to it I
came down here to dress
uh put that I put that on before I left
so I was ready so I got a little closer
second thing do if it calls you do it
anyway
you know I coined this phrase years ago
do it anyway
a buddy of mine
about the same time I was starting my
business I was having a lot of problems
in my life I was probably
it was before I started my business I
was still in Houston Texas I was going
through tremendous tremendous amounts of
uncertainty doubt about myself I was in
a transition a career transition and
just lost a job
starting my deal and
I went one year one year without working
I've never ever shared this before one
year and I did not I mean
I had a little bit of money saved and I
was going through it I didn't I didn't
literally I looked like I was working
every day but in truth I was not working
my twin brother actually knew that and
finally confronted me and that's what
got me off my ass but
this guy told me he's like look you wake
up in the morning and no matter what
you're feeling
no matter how much you hurt
if your eyes are bleeding do it anyway
that is a financial statement okay this
financial statement on this page is for
companies
individuals and households
every company a country a city every
company individuals you want to make a
note here
companies individuals and households
okay if you're a household a bill Bill's
a household he's got a household I know
he's got a household he's got to have a
house I don't know who's in the house
his household has a budget he's got
income coming in expenses going out
that's a financial statement that's what
that is right there income uh uh less
expenses equals what's left over period
end of story that could be Google
Facebook your house it could be a
company it could be a country it could
be a city they're all the same by the
way I go to Canada Japan I go to
Singapore Dubai Detroit and the
financial statement will be identical
the language will change the financial
statements will be identical everywhere
you go the top line of every financial
statement for a household or a company
or a city is what
Revenue income or sales okay this used
to be sales and then some account it how
many accountants in the room
some intelligent smart person okay said
oh we need to change that to Lake
to like Revenue
it used to be simple sales
okay and then somebody's like oh we got
to call that something better
okay we're gonna call it Revenue it
sounds more professional
dude it's sales okay how many of you
don't like sales
how many of you in a room let me see
your hand if you don't like sales okay
if you're no good at it you don't like
it
so that means everybody in the room is a
damn Masters Sensei how many of you love
watching my guys on on the on the uh on
the uh on the up here uh doing the sales
thing Dave Todd how good are those guys
are they good
and then I show up around 11 o'clock and
I show you a different variation you're
like dang dog
another level
you could be a black belt
that don't make you a sensei
right so like like I've done my thing
I've done my thing 30 years
there's a big difference between 30
years and six years
like I know every little crevice and I'm
still learning I know little little
angles
like one thing means a thousand things
to me not ten you understand because I
played the game a little longer so you
get deeper you get sensei
so there's a lot of levels to the game
man sales is about Revenue folks if you
don't like sales you want to write this
down if you don't like sales
you don't like Revenue
so get a t-shirt
I hate Revenue
I hate sales scratch it out but I hate
Revenue
[Music]
if you don't like sales you're in
trouble at home you in trouble for your
city you're in trouble for your
community you're in trouble everywhere
if you don't like income
because you unlike the government can't
print money it's against the law that's
why the America the United States
government the only product the United
States government has
is the printing of money there is no
other product
they print money so you work
you work you'll never create wealth okay
you want to write this down well no
matter how hard you work
okay
Kevin can work his ass off
he could work 20 hours a day
he will never create wealth work he will
only create wealth when he invests I'm
about to move I'm moving from Los
Angeles California where I've been 22
years in California my wife's been here
23 years she came here to be an actress
at 17 years old and we're picking up and
we're moving everything I wrote the
governor a letter three months ago and
said dude you keep raising my taxes I'm
out of here by the way you should be
doing that you should be thinking about
hey how can I avoid 7 8 9 10 or 11 state
income taxes most of you don't even know
what your income tax is you think when
you buy something sales tax is your
income tax I'm talking about the income
tax you pay on earned income that you
earned Jerry Brown didn't earn any of it
so I tell Jerry Brown I'm done dude if
you keep raising my taxes they're going
in that direction we're like okay we're
out of here now I got to tell you man it
is scary moving it is terrifying to move
I'm like I'ma move to Miami I'm gonna go
live in a new place we're gonna rent a
house for a while we're gonna figure out
we got to make new friends we don't know
anybody there all that stuff right
all the trouble figuring out the
calendar the money it costs to move all
that and then I'm like wait a minute
what are you worried about dude
you so pinned down to one place you
can't get up and move every once in a
while
it reminds me of how many people don't
want change the way it was is in the
past the way it's gonna be is in the
future so what is it going to mean a lot
of trouble me and my wife the kids new
furniture new house new place new
friends I gotta talk these guys here at
the company hey guys a year from now
maybe two years from now we're going to
shut this thing down in LA and you guys
are going to move over there with me but
look change is good don't be scared of
it you're not pinned down like like you
were like it's 400 years ago and you
lived in some village where they
convinced you that the world was flat
remember that I think that's why we get
scared of moving the World is Flat don't
leave the village you'll fall off
no you won't you're just going to change
you're going to evolve you're going to
make new friends dude if you need to
pick up and go some other place to make
your life better your family better to
find Great Schools to make more money
up and move advantages of multi-family
investing number one more doors the
easier to manage and fund the project
it's easier it's just an easier deal two
units harder to manage than 22 years
because the bigger you get the further
away you can get from it two units you
need a manager that manager is going to
charge you at least 10 or 12 percent
somebody's got to manage the property
somebody's going to answer the phone
calls four grand a month somebody's
going to want at least 400 bucks a month
to take phone calls number two all units
one location reduces management activity
number three one Closing one property I
could buy one deal get 300 units you buy
300 houses you need 300 closings four
one financial statement 300 units fits
on One financial statement one duplex
fits in the same financial statement
number five produce enough from new to
hire management team advantages of
multi-family you can hire management
team number six produces enough cash
flow to invest in capex capex circle
this word it means expenditure on the
capital of the building meaning the
Capital Improvements of the building
roof floors cabinets how many done
cabinets before use Graphics the guy
that wraps your cars in your city say
hey come wrap my cabinets I like things
done quickly I bought the house
Elena's not there I call my rap guy come
in here man
don't sand it don't paint it wrap it
boom it was done in an afternoon number
seven more units allow more amenities
two units you do not have a swimming
pool you do not have security you do not
have a gym 300 units you got a gym you
got security you got trees you got
picnics you got dog parks you got great
stuff you got Gates I have properties
where the pool at the apartment building
is nicer than the pool that we have at
our house and Elena's like where are you
going I said I'm going to the pool at
the apartment building I got some
apartment buildings if I was single
that's I mean I'd move in there
because they got action everywhere and
the bigger the deal is the easier it is
to add value and spend money on it right
if I'm gonna spend some money man I
could spin it cross it across a bunch of
stuff rather than two units so why do I
love real estate why does Real Estate
build Financial Freedom number one
protects your capital okay if if I buy
this deal is the money is the money is
the cash the money that I put down to
buy this deal is the money gonna be
worth more or less in the future
another cash
is worth less in the future what about
this building
only if by the way not all buildings are
worth more in the future
if the building's in a good location and
it stays occupied and rents can rise it
will be more worth more money in the
future okay I want you to be sure you
guys understand this not all real estate
goes up in value
you think it's good to be liquid
I would encourage everybody in the room
to stay illiquid
Wall Street wants you to be liquid the
banks want you to be liquid okay the
courts want you to be liquid your lawyer
wants you to be liquid
because as long as your liquid
they can grab it from you
you understand
like if you're liquid you're never going
to file for bankruptcy
you'll never ever tap into a bankruptcy
option
if you don't have a lot of debt you
can't use the bankruptcy courts
which are put there to protect you from
losing everything
now I've never filed bankruptcy because
my real estate got me through all the
hard times 2 000 2010 2020 covid my
apartment's got me through when our
other business hurt despite what you
guys saw in the news by the way when
rental apartment rentals we're going to
go to 84 70 percent the world was going
to go to hell we collected more rent
during covid than we collected the
previous year
did you even have the courage to borrow
money because if you don't have the
courage to borrow money you will never
have net worth and you will never have a
good credit score everybody agree
and you don't need to worry about your
credit score how many how many of you
you've been told you need to raise your
credit score in order to be free on this
planet no you need net worth
to be free on this planet excuse
completely made up
nobody needs a pair of fendi's and my
wife does not need six inch heels
everybody agree
okay you don't need all that stuff
but we made it up so you got a product
you got a service and now we can sell it
to people but you do need a place to
live and you need water and you need
food everybody agree I got to have
something over my head to shelter me
from the
the exterior I need some food and I need
some water those things will not change
no matter what happens with the internet
Amazon cannot replace housing
it can replace where you get your books
so when I'm watching Blackstone take
okay why are they taking currency
converting it to buildings
okay they take and write a check they
wrote a check for the entire thing no
debt 10 000 houses they then waited
filled it up with renters I'm watching
this in 2008 filled it up with renters
and then what they did was they refined
the entire process
sold it as bonds
to your grandmother
they pay your grandmother like two and a
half to three and a half percent
okay your grandmother's so happy that
every quarter she gets a little freaking
bang
they probably worked with AIG to do this
or State Farm or Allstate or Prudential
or MetLife or New York Life insurance
companies back most of my real estate
transactions
okay because real estate real estate is
is that thing that an insurance company
can use to depend on to pay for your
life benefit you got to be in the market
you got to be looking at deals you got
to have confidence you got to get debt
you got to have cash okay do not use the
last two as an excuse not to do a deal
shame on you
if you leave here and you keep blaming I
don't have the money and I don't have
the bank you don't need the money and
you don't need the bank you need the
damn deal to me interest-only loan is a
really great loan to get because because
you have a stable stable one of your
greatest expenses is now stabilized
completely meaning the debt will not go
up so if my my debt payments are 400
Grand a year they're never going to
change my taxes will keep changing my
expenses will keep changing employee
payroll will keep changing I need to
secure and stabilize as much as I can
so interest only is not really about the
asset class as much as it is about the
amount of Leverage you use anyone can
get what as long as you're working with
the right lender and the size of the
deal is right almost anyone can get an
interest only loan
so if you get down to 50 you're probably
good
just gotta ask your bank like that the
lady yesterday said oh we don't do
interests only guarantee they do
interest only
and you shouldn't be scared scared of
because what is principle and interest
anyway principal pay down is like a two
percent of a point and a half pay down
over
10 years over 10 years you're going to
pay down your debt maybe 15 percent
so rather than me putting 65 down I pay
50 down right now and it's interestingly
the whole time
all I'm doing is prepaying my pay down
to get the deal you need a commitment
you got to have a commitment when you
leave here you got to be like okay man
I'm gonna take my money how many of you
got cash in the bank right now
you have cash in the bank because you
don't have confidence in these deals
I don't have cash in the bank because I
trust my real estate more than I do my
cash how many you got a 401k good that's
because you do not understand the value
of Real Estate
because if you understood the value of
real estate the way I do you would not
have a 401k
that you can't access for 30 years
how many of you got equity in your home
excellent
and that just shows me that you do not
have complete confidence in the game
that I'm telling you right now because
if you had complete confidence in what
I'm doing you would not have equity in
your home you probably wouldn't even
have a damn home
you'd have your money sitting in 161
units somewhere paying you a check every
month
to make your house payment that you owe
money on so I want to give you a list of
things to drop
your drama no drama reduce your risk how
many of you'd like to never lose money
on a deal check off most of this list
and you won't lose money on a deal
number one is the location good
the better the location gets the better
off you are should have asked Robert
that would you rather pay a higher price
for a better location or a lower price
for a worse location I think I know what
he would tell me is it affordable
affordable to who
to the tenant not to you
you're not buying a box of groceries
here
is it affordable to the tenant based on
what else I can buy in that area Okay
New York City rents should be higher
than uh than a Miami rents
okay if if I'm in if I'm at Fifth Avenue
right in the every condo is 12 million
dollars
and I can rent there for 5500 bucks a
month for a little tiny apartment or if
I go to Silicon Valley and people are
being paid 250 250 000 to work at
Facebook as an intern
I can pay nine thousand dollar a month
in rent and those rents by the way you
have 1970
1970 built product it was built in 1970
Elena were you were you born in 1970
she wasn't even born yet and there's
apartments that were built in 1970 50
plus 52 years old
that rent for nine thousand dollars a
month one bedroom 800 square feet old
ass kitchen bad floors bad cabinets
leaky faucets that rent for nine grand a
month
and somebody bought those years ago I
guarantee they probably only paid 9 000
for the unit and every month they
collect another nine grand if they've
been there long enough okay is it so it
could be affordable right even though
it's nine thousand you take the rents in
Miami at 1500 2800 anywhere between 15
and 2800 you take that same asset you
take that and transport it to New York
City those rents are 25 000 bucks a
month
take the same property push it to
Singapore
Singapore rents are 80 percent higher
than the United States of America and
you guys complain about the rents you
guys complain about the rents because
the locals never change the market you
want to write this down the locals never
change the market The Outsiders did why
are Apartments Superior this is what I
want you guys to hear my flipper my
flipper friend in Austin the gentleman
with the Cardone Capital Hat number one
housing is a basic need number two
apartments are an economic Preferred
Choice number three apartments are the
preferred choice of housing today people
want to rent as an option they want the
mobility and the freedom to do so okay
number four it cannot be easily replaced
these 300 unit complexes that you're
seeing being built in the rallies and
the Carolinas all across the Eastern
Seaboard once it's there they're going
to build another one across the street
sooner or later it's all gone Houston
Texas this year consumed 50 percent of
all their inventory their apartment
inventory in the first five months of
the year this is called absorption
absorption is how fast new units are
being consumed okay or purchased they
can't be easy to replace what happens if
inflation happens to glass metal Lumber
we've had like crazy Lumber inflation
what about I can't get Workers to build
a 300 unit complex the housing
manufacturers they're not building
houses anymore they're building
apartment complexes number five it has
the potential to produce and provide
cash flow for the investors number six
bankable asset very very easy to get
dead on way easier than most every other
asset class number seven it's got a
multiplier effect two things on the
multiplier effect if you're taking notes
one rents can go up okay and The
Leverage from the property
this is the multiplier effect so if
these rents go up 200 bucks or 300 or 3
000 whatever number you want the rents
go up times 12 times 10 if you're gonna
hold for 10 years and what if they keep
bouncing is there any chance the rents
are going to go up the first property I
bought was in San Diego California 1998
okay we were moving the rinse two and
three hundred dollars every month
leverage leverage able assets
okay you want to make a note here to
create wealth you want to buy assets
that appreciate and value enough
refinance those assets at new higher
valuation pull out all their Equity to
create a non-taxable event meaning I
could get 50 million dollars and not pay
taxes and still own assets so if I could
just play this game one building at a
time I get a building wait three or four
years increase the rents get my money
out keep the building next go add
another Builder with the money that I
got from the first building you with me
and I just keep moving up
creating wealth for yourself you cannot
create wealth without investing doesn't
matter how hard you work nine number
nine you have multiple exits on this
stuff I could sell it I could refinance
it that's called an exit no exit grab my
money but I don't exit the property okay
number ten historic doubles every decade
Apartments double every 10 years in my
in Florida every 10 years to a a million
dollar deal doubles two million it
succeeded any of our expectations it's
just beautiful when you go from a doing
a a three million dollar deal where I
started a a I did my first deal was 1.9
million to looking at Billion Dollar
Deals you're going to take the same
trajectory I promise you I'm blessing
you guys right now this is what you're
gonna do you're gonna start with little
deals if you listen to me you'll skip
those but you can start there if you
wanted to you want to eat Cheerios you
can okay and or you could just like hey
let me go get the good stuff right now
I'm gonna I'm gonna eat off the top of
the shelf right now you just gotta have
imagination
right and not be limited to like I don't
have the money I don't have the
connections I I'm not in the I'm not in
the environment I don't know these
people good well you're going to get to
know these people
if I know them you can know them
and and so so when we have this trapped
Equity I'm like I'm trying to do these
big deals and I'm like I don't have the
money to do them
so I want you to write this down
what do you have
not what you don't have
what do you have right the question
needs to go from you know not I can't do
it to
how can I do it not what I don't have
what do I have
and or who has it so we basically made a
list who's got this money
okay without me selling my properties
because I do not want to sell my
properties
because if I sell my properties I'm just
going back to zero I could sell the
whole portfolio right now I'm just going
to go back to zero and have to start
over again I don't want to start from
zero I want to start I want to just add
to what I have right
so we made a list we started talking to
guys in The Brokerage business you got
to get a mortgage broker this guy
provesh is a mortgage broker how many
have we been through Ryan how many names
do you have
pravesh eight or nine yeah last two
years dude never rely on One on One Bank
or one lender
you want more lenders than you got kids
and wives and husbands
this polygamy
okay so we just start making a list of
lenders we started out with a I started
with a Regional Bank I started with a
local Bank San Diego National Bank in
San Diego they're out of business they
collapsed in 2010. they were taken down
by the federal government they were
replaced by another group the federal
government gave a group in Minneapolis
500 million dollars to buy the bank out
it's basically a takeover a hostile
takeover by the federal government
seizing property the guy the the guy
that owned the bank had 300 million he
could put in the bank to fund the bank
in 2010 and the federal government said
no
we're gonna give 500 million dollars to
a guy in Minneapolis
to buy you out and it was Federal money
tax dollars your money
was funded to another guy the club
they took this other guy out I owed I
owed 50 million to the bank of San Diego
when the new bank came in the new bank
said you need to pay your loans off I'm
gonna pay my loans off
yeah you're in violation you you have
technical default uh technical default
I've never missed a payment in my life
oh yeah but the asset value is because
the 2008 have collapsed
so and your net worth has changed
and the world has changed I'm like yeah
and by the way because you pay us is why
we're here we know you can pay we know
you have money and I had a bunch of
money sitting in a bank account
and they wanted to grab that money
that's what they wanted
okay the guys that didn't have money
they never called them
and I learned in 2010 I'm like hey don't
have a bunch of money sitting around you
got money sitting around they're gonna
come get that money when the world goes
to hell they go after people that have
money not people that don't have money
you want debt
you want lots of it
so so when I had 50 million in debt what
I learned in 2010 was I don't have
enough debt I said the next time this
[__] happens I might have two billion
dollars
I'm a sink a ship
[Music]
okay I'm I'm gonna they're gonna have to
pay attention to me because if you're
not big enough they're not going to pay
attention too big to what
exactly you guys need to get too big to
fail don't hate on the system man don't
hate the game don't hate the player
learn the game and be a player hey I
always tell you guys when you're picking
real estate out
make sure
that you never compromise
location okay look at this this location
right here some of you been
jabbing on me because oh Grant Cardone
doesn't take his own advice
he went and bought a house in Malibu he
says not to buy a house uh number one
this is not a house this is a piece of
art
located in one of the most popular
places in the country
and certainly in the state of California
this is beautiful Carbon Beach
it is 150 feet of Frontage on one of the
most desirable beaches in Malibu
and I'm saying this as humbly as I can
like on my guys look if you ever get a
chance in your life I'm not just
bragging here I'm just trying to show
you don't compromise location ever
the moment you compromise location you
can fix a lot of things I can fix the
paint I can fix the interior this
interior this house is very very dated
some people will like the cedar shake
the cottage look some people will like
that color not like the color the doors
and windows are dated they probably need
to be changed the pool at some point
needs to be updated it's 15 years old
some people will be all right some
people be like I don't like it it's just
a lab pool but it's 75 feet 75 feet of a
lap pool on Carbon Beach with neighbors
that are just
on every major list and it's just one
super super super desirable little spot
in the universe so when you're picking
real estate doesn't matter how big it is
this house happens to be 10 000 square
feet
Interiors three-car garage
two two stories sits up on caissons they
go 60 feet deep into the sand and it uh
the granite
to provide it with the space it's got a
75 foot lap pool
on
Pagosa like it's just gorgeous gorgeous
you can't build it again we tried to
build this again it would take probably
five years if you could get it approved
probably would not get ten thousand
square feet approved again
would not get the pool approved
and just a fantastic fantastic location
so for all of you that out there hearing
me oh Grant Cardone don't take his own
advice you're right man I mean I'm
telling you I would not
if I was on the come up just trying to
get my game on just getting started I
wouldn't go buy a house it doesn't
provide
my best friend cash flow if it doesn't
have cash flow what am I I gotta fund it
this house actually could provide me
with cash flow
and but if it didn't the location's so
ridiculous if I do the right things with
the interior and the colors and the
cedar Shake uh the doors and windows if
I update this pool a little bit
do the right things with the stone
furnace it on the interior in a way that
it should be
there's a real good chance
I make money on this house now you know
what I paid because it's been posted all
over the Internet what I paid for the
house when Real Deal posted it
in the Wall Street Journal
some of you like oh my God he overpaid
for this house how could this guy pay
that much money for this house
what do you think I'm going to sell this
house for in the future
150 feet there's three other homes on
Carbon Beach that have 150 feet on the
ocean none of it by the way is elevated
none of it most of it is down on the
sand you got Larry Ellison down the
street Michael Milken I mean these are
these are super super super wealthy
families Larry Ellison has one home his
son has building a brand new home that
they say will sell for 150 million if he
ever sells it
uh Michael milken's home they say is
worth a hundred and a half
when you are picking your home it could
be a 80
000 home
100 000
home
stretch if you're going to do it stretch
and get the best possible location you
can I made this mistake my first three
homes I made the mistake believing I'm
gonna buy for less in a great
neighborhood I knew I knew to buy in a
great neighborhood but I I was scared to
pay the extra money to be in that little
pocket of that neighborhood
where the location was literally
Irreplaceable
so if you're buying a house this year
you're buying an apartment or you're
buying an office building or you're
buying uh
retail or storage maybe storage less
okay make sure you get that kind of
location that's Irreplaceable I am not
going to invest with you if you don't
know what you're talking about
where is it I don't know
what's the job growth I don't know
what's the rent I don't know what's the
next door I don't know what's the NOS I
don't know okay no but next who's
serious number three not knowing you're
underwriting you got to know your
underwriting it's better for you when we
meet Wednesday night it's better that
you don't know you're underwriting with
me than when you do it with the bank
you do not want to mess up with the bank
they're not going to forgive you once
one time they're gonna be like leave
this guy alone they'll never forgive you
for it you will never they will never
you'll never get in their good graces
if you mess up with them one time
because they're cowards that's not their
money they're Lending
uh number four
You Gotta Buy through every cycle
you cannot wait for the bust out you got
to buy it through the good times you got
to buy through the bad times
you got to buy all the time
so before covet I was buying during
covet I was buying after covet I was
buying
so when I'm on a phone call with
somebody I was on a phone call today I
said guys they said what did you buy
during covet 600 million dollars worth
of stuff they're like dang man
like it shows tremendous confidence that
I can go do a deal through uncertain
times
number five buying too small buying too
small is a problem it's a headache it's
a pain in the ass okay six being talked
out of deals
leave the people around you alone get
somebody this Pro on this thing don't
talk to your stock broker or your
financial planner do not talk to your
dentist or your chiropractor about
buying real estate
let them
crack your back and then get off the
table
and go back to buying some real estate
uh number seven not looking at enough
deals these are the mistakes you're
going to make you're not going to look
at enough deals you're going to look at
a couple and quit keep looking at deals
they're going to stack the information
is going to stack I remember one of my
jobs was I was in a produce department
in Lake Charles Louisiana in a grocery
store and I was I was telling Jared
about produce the other day I was I
hated this job
the the guys tell me look man when the
bananas get some bruises on them
you got to move them to the front
I didn't know I was learning something
fast forward 50 years
when when an event's getting close to
being expiring
move that event to the front
you understand as you're losing time
because your product's going to get
bruised and expire move it to the front
like I didn't know when I was 16 years
old that I was learning
when I was stacking the shelves and they
taught me how to stack the Cheerios
and the brillo pads
and the tide and they told me how to
pull it to the front keep it squared up
I didn't know I was learning to pack
and control my environment
when you look at a lot of deals this
deal is going to teach you about that
deal it's going to teach you about that
deal and then one day you're going to be
like this deal right here is sick
because of these deals and you're going
to know for sure because you knew those
you because these gave you the data you
needed to buy that one okay one deal can
what
number eight I need to write a book one
deal could change your life as long as I
got money somebody will make for me yeah
as long as I have influence money as
long as I have the gold look if you have
the goal you make the rules but and that
is that has existed for thousands of
years it will not be a it will never be
violated that is the rule and and I know
people say it sounds terrible I I always
looked at this game like I want to have
the gold I want to make the rules I'll
find somebody that gave up on their
dreams billions of people give up on
their dreams every day you're never
going to fix you're not going to fix
that shortage overnight I would
encourage everybody to become more like
me so that at least you get on the other
side of this rainbow and say oh I know
what it looks like over here because
most people never even get why
because because people people ask this
question that you just asked
and and that question is based on a give
up it's based on a surrender to the game
okay should everybody play the game yeah
everybody should play the game should
everybody learn backgammon yes because
you should learn backgammon because it's
a cool game to play should everybody
learn how to make money uh yeah you
should because if you give up before you
do it
you'll never know you'll never know man
and I'm telling you money
like just this concept money won't make
you happy where did that come from
most people that say money won't make
you happy don't have any money or
they're trying to get your money yeah
and I'm gonna tell you money has made me
happier
as long as you get the right amount of
it
you're gonna get what you go look for
if you're looking for a purple elephant
you go find one this weekend even though
there's not one on this planet how many
of you can look for a purple elephant
look for one I'll bet you find one if
you look for a 32 unit deal you'll find
a 32 unit deal if you look for the
credit you find the credit you'll find
the debt you'll find the cash you'll
find the deals you'll if you're looking
for a partner you can find a partner if
all you do is keep looking for excuses I
don't have time I don't have money I can
do it I'm black I'm Brown I'm too young
I'm too old I'm a girl I'm this I got a
job I'm too young how old are you man
[Music]
and you're 19 years old man
it's time and I'm taking you under my
wings
okay
come spend two or three weeks in Offices
here in Miami we'll put you up you
cannot you can literally what's it
called the attorney
with me yeah
questions
I needed a man okay her his mom is
probably a great mom she can't be a mom
and dad
the better the mom you are the worse the
dad
so I'm a good father I am a terrible
mother
I'm like
my wife is saying we're on the 30th
floor yeah like I'm a father I'm a guy
right so I just it's a different vibe
and my mom tried to be a mom and a dad
and she couldn't
and so you be the mom you know I don't
know where your dad is but if I could
anyway and by the way the mom and the
dad can only do so much and then an
uncle needs to step okay
we'll hook you up okay all right guys
let's get back in here appreciate you
being here
I'll see you back
your department and your household has a
financial statement
if you if you look up the word economics
in the dictionary economics means
management of a household and this is
where people go a little fuzzy right now
you could be going fuzzy
what's he talking about this I'm talking
about your damn money
just right on here
that's what finances is it's my money
you know how many have you seen that
little t-shirt I got who's got my money
that's what this is a professional
baseball player said he was retired he's
a retired professional baseball player
he's like he's in business for himself
now he's like when you said who's got my
money he's like literally changed my
entire business
he's like I was spending time on a bunch
of complicated stuff
and wasn't doing what I knew to do in
baseball in baseball what is if you're a
batter what's the game
get on base
that is not hit them all it's get on
base
you could get hit by the ball
and you'll celebrate yourself
right it's get on base once you get on
base what's the next thing you want to
do
you want to advance
okay in finance you need to advance your
finances everybody agreed the way to
advance finances is not to to shrink the
bottom two-thirds of this statement it
is to grow the top line of the statement
same thing for your household your
household needs more income Chris the
police officer if he wants more money he
cannot reduce his expenses as far as he
can raise his income
you can only reduce your expenses to
zero everybody agree
I can only reduce so far
what can I do with income if Chris got
really creative how far could his income
go
it's Unstoppable it's unlimited he can
only no matter how bright he is or how
smart he is a company an individual
household can only take their expenses
so low you can change my life your money
cannot change my life you can give me a
stack of money as big as you want you
ain't got enough there's nobody on this
stream not one person on this stream a
combined 50 of you cannot change my
financial life it's impossible
but you could change my life your
charity could change my life it could
give us more purpose you could help me
with my Foundation
in your part of the world you could help
me with my legacy you could help my
children when I'm not here she's 30
years old maybe I'm not here and you're
in Singapore you're in Dubai or you're
in Lafayette Louisiana or you're in
Indianapolis and you see her and she
needs some help you can help me
you can help her but you can't help her
if you ain't got anything you don't have
a job an opportunity you don't have
money you worried about your own stuff
you can't even keep your own
refrigerator full how can you help
Sabrina
it's impossible
those of you who feel like he's
preaching at you it's cause you're
resisting
the lecture
you're resisting the answers those of
you who are like give me more bro give
me more I need the six pieces it's not
about having the six pieces of data it's
about executing the six pieces of data
so if I didn't care about you guys I'd
just go on my life and go buy another
piece of real estate tomorrow and then I
do a second deal and a third deal and a
fourth deal and a fifth deal if it was
just about the money okay so we're here
to help you stay here right now stay
here stay present you got to keep making
a decision
okay let me add a piece see Elena's
getting it right now Joe Joe mascali's
getting it Joe nice beard bro damn
incredible where are you where where in
the UK are you
in Essex just outside of London I know
where Essex is okay uh you're close
you're close to Saint Hill aren't you
what Sand Hill no
oh Sussex I thought you said Sussex okay
hey let me ask you something how often
do you have to take care of that beard
I pretty much stroke it a lot yeah you
stroked yourself a lot huh yeah I go I
go to The Barbers
you know get it lined up but that's
pretty much it yeah but every morning
every morning you you keep working it
out don't you 100 rush it out in the
morning yeah definitely there you go
thank you mate thank you for being here
okay now folks what is your beard that
you take care of every day because I
know a lot of you think man I just can't
stay with it
promise you
I'm gonna give you a list of things that
you can stay with in fact I want you to
write these things down I want you to
write down the things that you do every
day because a lot of you think you can't
stay with it and it's a lie
write down some things that you do every
day that take zero energy and you do it
every day Joe takes care of his bit
beard he calls it stroking
he didn't even call it take care of the
beard okay how many of you put makeup on
every day all you ladies out there every
day you do it okay you do these things
naturally I just want to recover for you
I want to recover for you your belief in
yourself
it is not true that if you that you have
failed you you are taking care of you
Stuart every day you're taking care of
your eyeballs right now
you're taking care of yourself every day
the problem is and this is what this is
what bran is talking about
the problem is you're not taking care of
the things that can get you up to the
top of the mountain you see this
financial statement right now right here
everybody has one some of you are seeing
one for the first time in your life
financial statements everywhere in the
world whether I go to Cincinnati or
Singapore they're identical I go to
Dubai or I go to Taipei or I go to
Sydney Australia financial statement the
languages are different the culture is
different the foods are different
everybody agree
the colors of the skin might be
different the financial statement is the
same everywhere
and they all start like this okay
there's there's there's this much of it
this the revenue of the company
typically there's this much revenue and
there's that many expenses
okay which one's more powerful
this is more powerful than that
okay I need to spend 95 of my time on
the top part of this you see where it
says Revenue gross sales Less sales
returns and allowances net sales that
little that little piece right there you
can take to Infinity
that you could take the zero and that's
it you can never get it lower than zero
and like if that don't Boggle your mind
if that little simple concept I can take
expenses to zero I can take gross sales
to to infinite how big can I imagine
okay how do I pay for the jet sales
how do I pay for the 19 country trips
sales
okay who's going to give me a sale
people the Top Line those top line is
people 95 percent of your time should be
spent on income and people people have
everything you want
the people that you know do not have
what you want the people that you don't
yet know have everything you've dreamed
of
so how old are you sir
57 years old the people that love him
and care for him that have taken care of
him that support him have had plenty of
damn time to change his life
he needs to now say okay I've been
looking at the wrong damn place
okay he now needs to meet the people
that can change his life because it's
not his mom his dad his uncle his
grandpa his kids the people that love
you are not going to change the quality
of your life they've had plenty of time
to do that
if you have money and you have health
and you don't have purpose and you don't
have interest and you don't have
excitement and you're not waking up
every day like hey I'm looking forward
to getting to the gym and working out if
you don't have those things going on I'm
going to go on a vacation I'm going to
spend time with my grandkids or my kids
or
I'm gonna write a book or something
exciting if you don't have that you're
going to burn okay so first of all let
me just say I don't know everything I
just know at 63 years old I'm in the
best shape of my life I'm in the best
financial condition in my life and I'm
the most excited I've ever been in my
entire life
that was not true just uh
16 year 16 years ago 17 years ago
is that right 63 12 years ago I'm sorry
12 years ago it wasn't that was not true
I was stressed I was burnt I had three
employees
two and a half employees
and only half of those worked
and I was doing all the work I was
running all over the country I was doing
250 days a year traveling picking up
checks was a Salesman basically you know
I was a
was sales was out selling pitching on
planes I was doing about uh 100 000
miles a year on American and United
buying a coach ticket
crossing my fingers hoping for an
upgrade stand at the Marriott on award
points you know the game right it was
away from my family had a new family at
the time I just got married was
traveling every day my quality of my
life was terrible and
I made a decision to get off
a challenge myself to get off the
treadmill of that treadmill now I knew
that I couldn't get off that treadmill
if I didn't have something else to go to
so I started studying people that have
scaled their finances
I need money to work for me I didn't
need to keep working for the money I had
a little bit of money put away but I was
terrified of it if you know what I mean
by the way if you're running this
channel for the first time more and more
people are using the YouTube channels
and the Instagram people our age are
using it to access information I dropped
I've dropped about 5 000 videos in this
Channel about sales marketing starting
over scaling health
finances real estate I started playing
this real estate game hard about 12
years ago I started spending more time
investing in real estate than I did on
picking up a sales check
I started pulling away from some of the
old ideas that I had been sold as a kid
by the banks in Wall Street which was
Diversified retirement accounts 401ks
IRAs I took my IRA and my 401K money
that and it was self-directed and I
basically took control of it and took it
away from Fidelity and a Schwab and Wall
Street I took that money away from them
a couple things that I did I went and
looked at my money I had money in
savings accounts check-ins accounts
money markets uh where else I had some
mutual funds I had ETFs I had 401ks and
Ira all of it either sitting in money
markets or Garbage Paper Stock and I
pulled all control of that money back
over I also had equity in a home I
grabbed the equity at home I sold the
home
and went and rented I literally reworked
the entire finances in my life just keep
this in mind think about this you don't
have to go do it today and you don't
have to you don't have to be right or
wrong on this deal
[Music]
nobody talked to me about marketing but
when I studied and this is really really
important for everybody you guys start
studying successful people
you know if you want to be a Salesman
the rest of your life to live off
commissions the rest of your life great
study the best sales people out there
but I'm gonna tell you something if you
want to make your life easier
start figuring out how to scale your
sales
and the way to scale your sales is
through marketing I'd rather have 10
people buy from me than one people than
have to sell one person
yeah you know I don't want the hard sale
anymore I want the easy sales and this
isn't about like yeah I don't mind
working hard I got I know how to work
hard but I don't want to work hard every
day
I'd like to work more
at collecting more fruit that wants to
fall off the tree the easy sales and
marketing is the only way to make sales
easy word tracks do not make the sale
easier I mean they'll make it better
you know it'll handle an objection uh
follow-up you know tremendous follow-up
will make more we'll we'll almost
guarantee you a sale but in between the
follow-up if you want to speed up your
sales cycle for instance if you're in a
sales cycle that typically is very very
long the only way to make that sales
cycle shorter is through marketing and
trust and marketing is the only thing
that builds trust it's not what you say
how you say or how you dress it is the
frequency at which you show up in
people's ideas or thoughts it's called
omnipresence and we'll teach you how to
do that in January I was presenting in a
way that appeared confident and
self-assured
and that the person asking the question
actually doesn't know whether I'm
confident and self-assured you don't
know
see it was his perception of me not the
reality so I basically wrote this
article about five tips to handle
insecurity and I want to share them with
you right now the number one thing you
need to know about fear doubt and
insecurity is this most important thing
everyone has them everyone experiences
them it's not like oh my gosh I am so
I'm so vulnerable and so weak and so I'm
so insecure dude everybody has it I
don't care they're three or four or five
people maybe over the entire history of
the world that haven't experienced fear
insecurity and doubt the rest of us are
normal okay I have it all the time I
have fear insecurity and doubt
constantly and I'm going to tell you how
exactly how I'm going to handle those in
the next four steps the first thing I
want you to know is this it's common
everybody experienced it nobody's Beyond
it it doesn't make you bad or weak okay
you don't need medication for it okay
it's normal number two fill your
calendar up a trick I play with myself
not to deal with fear is I feel my
calendar I pack it so tight I'm
literally starving fear because fear
needs time if you jam your calendar no
white space on a calendar you'll starve
fear
fear lives on time okay number three you
want to use the fear look whatever I'm
scared of doing I do it as quickly as
possible okay I actually look for things
each day that I'm scared to do the
things that I don't want to do the most
the call that I don't want to make the
visit I don't want to do the letter I
don't want to send out the email I don't
those things are the first things on my
list I literally use fear like a
trampoline I want to jump into it jump
into it and hope I get some bounce out
of it fourth thing I want you to do is
start going beyond your comfort zones
you got to get outside your comfort zone
90 of people
want to be comfortable I want to feel
good I want to do what feel good that's
how we end up with you know big Slurpee
drinks with too much sugar in them and
you shoot drugs in your arm you smoke
weed you go out with a girl or a guy
that you you know they're no good for
you but you wanna feel so good
successful people don't want to feel
good they want to feel great successful
people don't want to be comfortable they
want luxury you see the difference do
what you're uncomfortable doing the way
to get luxury is to be uncomfortable not
to see Comfort get off the Lazy Boy a
lazy boy is for Comfort okay you got to
get into activity do the things you're
uncomfortable with go places where
you're uncomfortable visit people you
don't know yet get out of your comfort
zones the last thing I want you to do
number five is I want you to multiply
times 10. I talk about it in the 10x
rule everything you think you need to do
multiply times 10 okay you dream this
High multiply times 10 and raise it way
up 10x everything okay do it as fast as
you possibly can know that fear and
doubt are normal they're normal 10 extra
activities to where you're like bing
bing bing bing bing bing bing when
everybody else quit you're still bing
bing bing bing bing and you're still
taking action when the next two guys
drop off you're still hitting it okay
the first two guys did 20 things you do
200 last and standing it's a rule in the
marketplace Last Man Standing
think in terms of actions not action
there is no one action that you can do
that is so unbelievable that it would
make a difference you can't tell me one
action hit one home run nobody will pay
attention to you hit a hundred home runs
and the world will pay attention you
know being an entrepreneur is one of the
most exciting
things that you can do with your life
and the possibilities are endless one
aspect of running a business that I get
asked a lot okay over and over almost
every seminar I go to somebody will walk
up to me and say dude how do you handle
burnout and my reply is fast and simple
I don't believe in Burnout that's right
I don't believe in Burnout now I know if
you're experiencing the the exhaustion
that is associated with this idea of
burnout that nobody can prove by the way
that this seems impossible to you that
burnout doesn't exist but I'm telling
you listen to me burnout is not real
it's made up
take a step back for just a second while
I try to sell you on this idea and try
to remember a time when you are on fire
on fire lit up excited about being an
entrepreneur see that's gone right
yeah Grant I'm burned out that's what
I'm telling you no no no no go back to
the time when you were lit up on fire
you couldn't sleep at night you didn't
need to eat okay all you needed was the
idea of a future you had for this
dreamness idea this business whatever
see at that time you were goal driven
the possibilities were enormous they fed
you you were Mission driven
see it's when the mission's missing it's
when the mission goes away that a person
starts to experience being tapped out or
burned out or exhausted at least this is
my experience look when I'm not tapped
fully into my future my goals the
potential the possibilities I don't care
what the job is whether it was me when I
was working at McDonald's the country
club I was working on a rig down in in
in the Gulf of Mexico or whether I was
writing my first book look when your
goals aren't big enough
when you're no longer sold on your
vision your purpose your mission the
symptoms of losing interest what many
call burned out burnout or experienced
anytime you stop reaching for massive
success the next thing you start
settling in
getting comfortable listen settle to
settle
oh I just want to settle down dude why
don't you just put a once you just
decide to be to hate your life every day
see that's when you start having
problems when you start selling that's
why comfort and complacency are the
entrepreneur's worst enemy in fact I
would tell you this the comfort and
complacency are everybody's worst enemy
the only time I've ever gotten in
trouble in my life was when I was bored
complacent when I was settling who wants
average who wants average nobody wants
it okay nobody no matter where you're at
in life you don't want average
but we're surrounded by average people
every day average ideas average products
average advertising only those that have
given up on greatness
would settle for average in the United
States today we often hear people say I
just want to be comfortable look folks
that is very dangerous that is very
dangerous to consider the idea of
comfort such Comfort mentality is what
sets entrepreneurs and businesses apart
it's what makes people great is saying I
don't want to be average consider
business
consider the number of businesses or
maybe even people you know that were
once great they were on fire they were
doing great things
and they settle down into complacency
they started resting on their Laurels I
recently was written by a woman
this is maybe 10 days ago she told me
thank you grant today I was fired I said
what I read your book the 10x Rule and
the same week I was fired for being
super competitive
this woman was fired for being too
competitive too on fire and by the way
Grant thank you because I had six job
offers by the end of the week
see folks that's where you want to be
even if you're at risk entrepreneurs are
often criticized for working too hard
have you been criticized lately be
criticized be obsessed over your future
be consumed by the possibilities and
people will criticize you the ambitious
should never apologize
for the only people that criticize them
are the people that have given up the
ambitious should never ever apologize
because the only people that criticize
them are those people that have given up
get excited be excited stay excited and
never settle hey how do I grow my
business 10 times not one or two times
how could I scale my business out so
that I have maybe you have a hundred
customers or 200 customers how could I
have 2 000 customers you got two
thousand how could I have twenty
thousand customers this is what the big
companies do you got four employees that
you don't like how could I have 40
employees
and have somebody else handle
the 40 that I don't like
because what's happening right now is
people are scaling down when they should
be scaling up
if you don't like your financial
condition look at your environment
my my financial condition has been an
indication of the people around me and
when I'm listening to every day if you
don't have something I'm not talking
about a book right now I'm talking about
you guys need to be buried in content
buried immersed how many of you heard
this just saying uh drink I'm drinking
the Kool-Aid
you need to swim in it
you need to drown yourself in it you
need to immerse yourself inject it into
your arm you need to smell it breathe it
love it drink it immerse yourself in
whatever Kool-Aid you're going to drink
be all in No One's Gonna come to your
house and make your dreams come true it
won't happen it's not going to come
through the TV not going to come to you
on Facebook it's going to become because
you have a place to go
every day and get your head right
your attitude right how many believe
you're in an attitude business first
oh wow
seven people
yeah I'm all in man I'm all in how many
you got people on your team like this
man yeah yeah man I'm gonna do good man
I'm gonna do good I'm I'm going after
how many of you heard people building
teams say I can't find good good people
yeah what's the point
why are you telling that to other people
why do you tell that to other people why
are you trying to make sense and not
finding good people you get what you
think and say every day
I can't find any good people seven
billion people on planet Earth you can't
find good people because you quit
you quit
[Applause]
so you just need to know the truth when
you criticize anything you're saying
something about yourself see I don't get
rid of haters I I'm like come on man
bring it on dog tell me about yourself
you talk about money too much you ain't
got any
oh you work too hard you don't work hard
enough
you too cocky you ain't cocky enough
why you gonna blame my swag because you
ain't got any
huh
you left yours at somebody's house
somebody told you you were an introvert
you bought into it right somebody said
you're shy and you bought into it
somebody said you don't need to have a
business you don't need all that you
don't need a jet you don't need the big
house you don't need a bunch of money do
you gave up I didn't
keep it to yourself you don't need to be
contagious
okay people quit this organization and
what do they do oh yeah right what do
they say never write this down never
ever take advice from a quitter if you
quit anything
man I quit going to the gym it just
didn't work for me I don't need to hear
that from you
I'm going to get different information
from the people still going to the gym
would you agree look if you don't
believe in you enough to invest in
yourself every day I don't have time I
got the kids I got the wife I got the
marriage I got the problem I got the Boy
Scouts I got this dude you're sold on
something else I don't even know what
you're talking about right now
you're you're manufacturing excuses
to contaminate other people I don't need
to hear about all your problems I don't
care oh you guys saying I don't need
this and I don't need that I don't need
that oh my God why you gotta have all
that how can you know what you want
when you ain't never done it
just keep it real man I'm sitting here
on the front of a damn 180 foot yacht
leaving Monaco
telling my buddy Brandon back there I
said bro my whole life
my whole life I have been
guilty of saying I didn't need this or
that without even knowing what this or
that was
let me tell you how many times I said
now I don't need yacht
who needs a yacht nobody needs a yacht
I've never been on a yacht man
okay like take a Jacuzzi on this yacht
while you leave other yachts in Monaco
you do this one time and I guarantee
you're going to start thinking God damn
man how can I get me a yacht you know
what I'm saying I'm just keeping it real
with you this 10x thing makes you think
big makes you act bigger
and get you around some stuff where
you're like maybe I do need a yacht
now fortunately or unfortunately I've
given this experience to my daughter
which she will never ever forget
I hope you guys more unfortunately a
year because when you can't forget it
you can't forget it you're like God dang
I'm gonna go back to that life it's like
flying private you fly private one time
and man you will hate boarding Southwest
Airlines
this is fantastic man this is how
everybody should live and I'm sharing
this with you guys just so you know man
how can you know what you want when
you've never even seen it been around it
nobody's sharing it with you they're not
talking about how cool it is and good it
is because I know there's a whole bunch
of people in here gonna hate on me
because I'm showing
me and my family living on a yacht for
two weeks in the south of France I know
people gonna hate on me for that why
though why are you hating
on somebody just trying to share a
billion dollars worth of game for free
you understand I'm just telling you
share this with somebody that's always
already tell you I don't need to be rich
I don't need to be married I don't need
to have kids I don't need the vacation
in the world I don't need a car I don't
need you know uh the dream
how would you know
if you've never had it
if you've never experienced it
these are balloons for one my daughters
Scarlett okay she didn't know she needed
that but she knew she wanted it
okay made me feel good to be able to do
it for her
so look
just remember the next time make an
agreement right now the next time you
say I don't need all that just ask
yourself have you even had that
do you even know what that smells like
on Open Sea in a Mediterranean
to do a trip like this and bring a bud
say hey man I got you bro
okay to bring my kids my wife on a trip
and not have to worry about the money
every second
I used to take vacations I worried about
the cost of it before the trip while I
was booking the trip during the trip and
definitely worried about it after the
trip
yourself in a situation where you can do
anything with the people that you love
and care for look I'm looking at castles
come on
these five days it's 90 minutes a day
you guys carve about 90 minutes for me
every day for five days completely free
cost you nothing
and I promise you I will put you on
track to become a millionaire yeah man
you know so it's not difficult you got
you I can't do the willingness thing you
guys got to sign up for it I can't do
and I know some of some of your audience
are like ah what's the strings the tads
what's it uh the strings I want to help
that's the string okay if you've ever
asked for help beg for hell prayed for
Help Wanted help wanted somebody to take
time to help you this is a gift yeah and
it's my gift to you and those that
receive the gift it gives me a gift back
to me to fulfill my purpose so I truly
want to help people uh this is not about
inspiration or motivation it's not about
you getting all excited beating your
chest it's real tactical dude it's a
strategy it's a specific strategy yeah
and I'd like I've never needed
motivation I don't need anybody to
motivate me I don't need to jump up and
down to get excited I don't I don't need
to do a cold plunge to want to conquer
the world or walk on fire dude I need a
strategy just show me the math yeah and
and show me that and then I'll I'll take
it from there and I'm gonna figure it
out just like you did I've created
leverage on my Leverage
on your leverage on your leverage on
your leverage on your leverage you
leverage your leverage like 15
000 times it's unbelievable
yeah I like like in 12 years I didn't
know I could do this right it was
because people started believing Envy
Man one and and then and then when I
started seeing other people do this when
it became real to me
you know that
you know when I saw oh wow what was I
thinking
what was I thinking I'll tell you one of
the biggest culprits
one of the biggest thieves in our
society and one of the biggest mistakes
I made in my career was like simply just
not being around the right people
I was around people that loved me when I
should have been around people that had
done something
you know oh man I love her so much I
love this but they hadn't done anything
like like guys you know you can love you
you know
you need to get around some people that
have done something so you can take care
of the ones you love
because if you're not around people that
have done something you can't really you
can only do to the degree that you're
around winners
I'm sorry your golf game's not going to
get better playing around guys that
don't know how to play golf I was 28
years old three years sober no drugs in
my body for three years I'm selling cars
and I'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look I got bad credit
and I'm not buying today I'm like oh
that's two cars
I'ma penalize you for saying that boom
okay okay you got bad you got bad credit
that's perfect
at least you got some credit
see I ain't positive I'm there to get
something
so so Captain Ryan says to me he's like
you're the most positive person I know I
said dude I'm not positive at all
I'm 10x
I get results
okay I want to get the deal done I want
to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
I was positive or not they're going to
remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
understand when you go to Whole Foods
and they say hey that'd be 427 for three
bags
[Music]
and you're like I got a good attitude
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10xes and money to
go with your freaking attitude
I was 30 years old and I was starting to
speak around the country
a business partner that I've been
working with for three or four years he
said look I said dude I'm a crossover
I'm working on this one vertical how
many how many of you dependent upon a
vertical
maybe you're a chiropractor or a dentist
or insurance or you're in real estate or
you're you work you're you're Sprint
right and you got this vertical and
you're like dude I love my vertical my
vertical makes me feel good my vertical
pays the bills oh
I do that
upon the vertical I'm a little worried
that that that that that you know what
I'm saying
I got to keep doing this thing
and I kept telling this guy I said one
day I'm gonna cross over to a mass
audience he says you'll never do it
nobody ever does it McGraw-Hill McGraw
Hill you know the book publisher McGraw
Hill
they wouldn't publish
a book called seller be sold because
they said it was a sales book
I say yeah and I'm a Salesman books too
National Geographic canceled the
turnaround King how many of you saw that
show
canceled it CNBC copied it picked it up
threw it up on the thing
look this is what's gonna happen to you
folks how many of you have a dream
[Music]
hey hey you gotta go get it
okay dreams don't happen on couches and
they don't happen in bed if you're gonna
realize that dream you got to go out
into the marketplace you gotta meet a
new you
you got to go through obstacles and
barriers to where it's like it doesn't
even bother me anymore
right Elena 26 phone calls because I
wanted to close the deal
she doesn't want to go out with me I'm
too short yeah okay I'm too short how
short am I at 51 000 feet
[Music]
how short am I now
I sure did my now God damn
I showed him right now we're scoring 666
miles an hour right now at 51 000 feet
huh huh I'll show them an hour
the plane that I bought it was an
expansion decision
the accountant said it doesn't make any
sense man you don't fly enough it's
gonna cost you too much
you don't go on those trips I'm like
dude am I going to expand or contract
it's been 30 years 30 years it's
probably going to be 30 years for you to
doubt uncertainty insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
going to be 30 years of it if anybody
thinks
you're going to be successful without
paying that price
you're wrong are you willing to pay the
price
who do you need to be connected with
long term because you're going to have
to change your friends
you're going to have to I don't I don't
mean get rid of the friends and family
that you have but you're going to have
to add some new friends new family new
peeps a new network you know they say
your network is your network you guys
well that's true for you to keep scaling
10xing 60.
600 6 million it's all possible I
promise you if I can do it you can do it
I went from being a guy that was a
one-man show one-man show to running
companies I've got 200 employees here
350 in our real estate uh Partners all
around the world and it's only because
of these four things I'm going to share
with you in the 10x income system which
is
first mental second and second is hey
what is my strategy to get to the next
level three three is am I in the right
vehicle picking the right Vehicles okay
real estate's a great vehicle uh
coaching's a great vehicle Healthcare is
a great vehicle
um uh education is a great vehicle I'm
in all these but by the way right now
using online today the metaverse is
going to open up all kind of
opportunities for so many people I'll be
right there webinars online uh
phenomenal opportunity for everybody out
there if you're in the situation right
now you don't like it you don't like
where you're at you don't like what
you're doing you're limited you're stop
you're stuck okay grab this take
advantage of it I'm telling you it's a
game changer it's going to give you what
you need what you need
what you need
so that you can have what you deserve
everybody deserves a great life
everybody deserves the ability the
ability these guys will go crazy if I
come in here okay you deserve the
ability to um
uh to uh
Hey make more money period because the
truth is if you don't make more money
you'll never have money to invest and
you'll never get to the second Hustle
the third one the fourth one you'll
never get to the multiple flows and I
want to show you here how to get
multiple flows of income literally I
have three income flows today that I do
nothing
and they provide me with income every
single month what are you gonna do when
are you gonna start doing it
this isn't about a convention a
conference it's not about enthusiasm
you need to smile yeah you need to smile
you need to smile like you're crazy
you need a smile when you're not winning
okay but you need to do something folks
and you need to do it 10 times and then
a hundred times and then a thousand
times and if you do it enough times
you're gonna win
you're gonna get to sit wherever you
want in life on whatever plane seat
whatever Hotel you want to be at stay as
long as you want come and go as you want
if you don't want to go you're like dude
just cancel the plans
but but we're inside of 24 hours they're
gonna keep our money keep it
I can get some more
it wasn't even mine
okay the money I got in my pocket right
now nope see Elena's got it all
the money Elena has in her purse
with somebody else's money
see but we're taught that there's a
shortage in their scarcity and you don't
have any all you have to do is be
willing to call somebody
talk to somebody
make contact
if it's not getting you the result tweak
the contact and increase the calls
and by the way if you don't want to do
two things don't tweak
and just increase the calls
if I call enough people I can say
anything I want to say
okay if you're taking notes write this
down no one thing will ever blow a
prospect
no one thing will ever blow a prospect
there's nothing you can say that will
not one thing most people don't know how
to create money okay the most important
thing about money and getting what you
want is not to have the money it's to
create the things you want live where
you want have the expansion you want the
views you want go where you want number
one you have to know how to make it most
people don't know how to make money
number two fewer people know how to keep
it that's discipline you got to have
discipline and you're not going to have
discipline if you don't have goals why
would I keep money
if my goals are either perverted
short-sighted or maybe too small okay so
you got to have monster goals and and
that's going to create the discipline
necessary to keep what you went out and
earned and number three number three
then you got to figure out how to
multiply it okay now you don't need to
figure out how to multiply it when I was
25 years old and I'm broke I didn't need
to work on multiplying it I didn't even
need to work on keeping it because I
didn't have any
in the beginning in the very beginning
from the age of 25 to 35 all I did was
work on particularly in the first three
or four years all I worked on all I
worked on was how do I learn how to sell
man I think it's bright how do I learn
how to sell how do I learn how to Market
how do I learn how to promote how do I
learn how to handle people's objections
I'm talking about basic basic stuff when
I met Elena I called my mom I said I met
my wife today
[Music]
she's like have y'all been out yet I
said no she hates my guts
[Music]
she wants nothing to do with me okay
kind of like I felt about Pete the first
time I met Pete
I told Jared I said I want nothing to do
with him
it's a true story piece like can I get
five minutes sure
sure I'll give you five minutes might be
15 seconds boom he made an impression
with me first impression is
what's first impression
last Impressions more important than our
first impression most the People You
Meet they're gonna have a bad first
impression of you
okay most of the people I meet do not
like me my wife had she did not not like
me she didn't even see me
she didn't like I was invisible to her
she couldn't remember what had black
hair brown hair short top she didn't
remember nothing like she's like huh who
are you I met you last night huh
yeah you know the god the god the guy in
the RV uh-huh so so look no matter what
you do there's gonna be people that
don't know you
right you're going to be humble Elena
did not know me did not want to know me
did not want to get to know me my mom
said Grant if she don't like you it
takes two grand it takes two how many of
your parents told you that before it
takes two you gotta have two people in a
marriage and I told my mom thank you
thank you Mom
thank you and I hung up and I'm like she
wrong again
it don't take two folks it takes one
person to make a relationship or
takes one person to make a sale you know
I mean things I've sold in my life where
nobody wanted to buy it
okay almost probably probably eighty
percent of everything I've ever sold
with some to someone that didn't want to
buy it
the other 20 wanted to buy something
from me
last thing I'm gonna say it was his idea
and our idea to get you here
you you you got sold this
you didn't buy this you understand that
okay don't be saying oh yeah I bought it
no you didn't you got sold this
okay we sold you on coming here you this
wasn't your idea you didn't call them
say hey I'd like to come down to the 10x
headquarters
I'd like to give you guys money spend a
couple days they're learning right
in fact uh would you you could do a
challenge put a challenge together and
sign me up for a lot of others as well
no no this was our idea to get you here
[Music]
okay and that's the same thing that's
gonna happen for your audience it's not
going to be them wanting to do something
with you you got to decide it takes one
person to make a sale
never takes a buyer almost never takes
the bar
takes me to walk up and say this is what
we're doing Apple computer has two 196
billion dollars in cash today they will
borrow money tomorrow morning debt is
good some debt is good debt and there's
not a wealthy company on this uh Planet
not one wealthy company on the planet
earth that is cash free that does not
use debt I don't want to get out of debt
I want to create wealth and the way to
create wealth is through debt and the
debt is cheap the debt is under three
percent
I pay interest only I don't even pay the
mortgage down so basically what I'm
doing is prepaying my mortgage
massive amounts of margins I'm paying
down in the beginning so it stays stable
my debts stays stable and the asset goes
up in value so like a house you see the
problem with a house and you shouldn't
even have this comparison of
conversation because if I buy a house
for let's say the house is the average
house about 240 000 in America and I put
five percent down you're probably over
leverage right there
why would they give me that loan and the
house doesn't provide any income back I
want to check every month I don't want
to check every quarter I want to check
every month I don't want to check 10
years from now dude I want that paper
back today I want to sell to the Goldman
Sachs and the black stones of the world
you you can't start there but you can
level the game up to play there I am not
here to satisfy you I am not here so you
like oh oh Grant I like him I don't care
if you like me or not man I want to move
a handful of people in the room to go
from 400 Grand a year to start thinking
about how do I make 4 million big boy
right over here popping out what do you
what'd you make last year
what'd you gross last year
2.7 how does anybody live on 2.7 million
dollars a year
impossible dude
I can't my my plane eats 2.7 million
dollars a year
this dude needs to think different
he's running out of time man you got
you get so frothy with opportunity it's
unbelievable you're making sense of less
than you can get this is my mama my Mama
saying I love you boy just the way you
are Mama I made 10 million dollars on
one deal that's great but son I love you
just the way you are I'm like I don't
love me just the way I am
because I'm doing deals where I know I
could make a hundred
okay how many of you in the room are
operating below your potential let me
see a hand if you know you're operating
below your potential man please tell me
you operate how many of you let me see
your hand again if you're operating
below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it all
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm gonna quit thinking I'm going to
quit thinking that I that I got to do a
four minute mile
I'm gonna quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars Worthy
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied
okay I want to raise the numbers on this
room
so the next time there's 75 people here
and everybody adds a zero to your income
oh by the way if you love yourself at
400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like I do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway good then
get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
get paid some real money just had a zero
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said I
ain't got add I don't know how to add I
multiply
I'm done adding I'm done adding a
customer I want to multiply customers I
want to I don't want to add orders I
want to multiply my orders okay I
consider myself a decent salesperson
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros
because you're going to hit you're going
to hit a place where they can't pay you
anymore right or wrong
you got to start thinking about being a
business inside the business
how do I add zeros how do I grow the top
line of my business okay so today I'm
thinking I'm thinking man I'm going to
build a mo I'm gonna build a 10 billion
dollar business I just go into it
backwards I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I'm gonna take
the 14 little things that I have
probably get down to three or four how
do I build 10 billion
I know the money's on the planet
say yay if you agree there's 10 billion
dollars on planet Earth dude you could
you could suck 10 billion dollars off
planet Earth today and you wouldn't they
wouldn't even give you like you wouldn't
even make the paper
I just got to think different and I
can't compare it to my upbringing
have you ever seen how people talk about
different days of the week
you know like oh man I hate Mondays or
Wednesday's hump day or hey thank God
it's Friday or my God I can't wait till
the weekend when you hear people say
things like Mondays this I hate it
Wednesday's hump day oh my God I can't
wait to the weekend you are talking to
people that whether they know it or not
are unproductive people unproductive
first in their minds limiting their
potential and their ability to produce
at higher levels because they are
basically taking four days of the week
and throwing them away I hate Mondays
Wednesday's hump day no Wednesday and
hump day do Wednesday is the fourth day
of the week first of all most people
don't know uh zilch about the days of
the week Sunday's the first day not the
last day Monday's the second day
Tuesday's the third day fourth day is
Wednesday the fifth day is Thursday
Friday's the sixth day and Saturday is
the finish of the week
otherwise you don't know what you're
talking about okay and you can't waste
any of them you only have a handful most
people don't even know how many Sundays
they have but they talk about their
weekends being the greatest time of
their life and the truth is most people
just get in trouble on the weekends okay
what am I telling you here I'm telling
you this got to start paying attention
to your time your thoughts your ideas
and you got to start paying attention to
the people that are around you and what
they think if the people you hang with
hate Mondays you're not going to be very
productive on Mondays would you agree if
Wednesdays is a day named after camels
and you don't live in the desert you're
just freaking confused and if the
weekend is the only thing you got
cherished boom you need to blow your
brains out because your life is going to
be long
ugly and unproductive
that's not a normal State that's lazy
okay
that's not normal to be putting your
head down on a table to not be moving
snap and pop do not be adding
mood look lazy as I wrote in this recent
article that was read by almost 4
million people with I think as of today
14 000 likes and just as many dislikes
even people rageful and angry maybe
you're getting like that right now about
my article that lazy is the new
entitlement look just see if this
describes you or anyone you know I only
do enough
I make as little as possible I save as
little as possible I invest as well as
possible I learn as little as possible
and hey I work as little as possible and
when my five days are over with each
week I have to I must take Saturdays and
Sundays off I'm entitled to it these are
the policies of the lazy and they are
ruining our country they're ruining
anyone that operates with them okay
normal a normal state is not lazy a lazy
person is actually educated encouraged
acknowledged and it's allowed lazy is in
a loud state in organizations so if you
see anybody in your group in your
organization in your family this lazy
hey knock it off man it don't work you
end up with too little money not enough
love not enough work and not enough
customers lazy is a failed policy and
I'm here to wake you up about it I want
to talk to you today about success all
right I want to I want to how many of
you like to have success in your life
okay what does that mean to you though
you're gonna either go get it or
somebody else is going to go get it
there's two types of people people that
are going to get what they want and the
life they want and people that don't
life is bad for too many people good for
a bunch of people and great for this
many the biggest problem I had when I
was 15 was I was bored too much I didn't
know anything about potential I knew I
had potential
but the biggest reason I was bored is
because I wasn't going after my
potential all the time I challenge you
this summer to only be focused on hey
man what's my potential no matter how
good you play your video game no matter
how good you are in school no matter how
you good you are on the field there's
another place where coach is trying to
push you to that next level and that's
where it gets exciting you want goals
that are so big so big that every day
you wake up and you're excited and the
reason I wasn't excited when I was your
age
was because nobody was telling me man
have some goals man
because if you don't have your own goals
this is what you're going to do you're
going to spend your whole life
making somebody else's dreams come true
this is what you should walk away with
today the gap
the Gap is the difference between where
you are where you sit right now and what
and where you want to be we're going to
give everybody a copy of this one it
says I am greatness don't fight it
intention is senior to mechanics
it's like that that was a game changer
for me I'm like man I need to keep for
me that means like
my understanding of that concept is the
intention where I want to get
not not am I a good person or not the
intent what the goal or Target is needs
to be 80 percent
of my energy
so I'm going to get to 5 billion now the
next thing I'm going to do
I'm not going to take a piece of paper
out I might take a piece of paper out
figure out how many deals I need to do
but that's where it becomes problematic
because I'm like okay if my average deal
size is 50 million and I need to get to
50 billion I need a thousand deals right
like I ain't got I can't I can't even
buy one deal right now much less a
thousand and then you get stuck in this
problem this bigger problem
and then you're like there's no way and
you give up on your goal and your
intention now and then you start cutting
everything
that's why if you've ever heard me say
never reduce the target that's what I
was talking about don't reduce the
target increase the activity
to the point to where your goals in my
case my goals should be so big that it
gives me new questions to ask
and the new question would be who do I
need to meet to do a 50 billion dollar
deal right right the buddies that I have
right now in clubhouse Jonathan Jerry
Glenn David spezak Brian been stuck they
can't help me dude correct
those people cannot help me get to 50
billion they can they can they can be
buddies sure
so that's why if you look at that list
of people I gave you earlier that I'm
studying oh yeah
they've all done 50 billion and more
right
so that's what I need to start real say
what did these cats do who who do they
know what do they now now I'll just tell
you another thing that that is crazy
because I just found this out I was I
was talking to some Wall Street guys and
I'm like do that I hate these Wall
Street people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at me says bro it's because
you're talking to the wrong people he
didn't say bro by the way but he says
it's because Grant he's like Grant
you're not talking to the top of the
food chain
the top of the food chain
is exactly like you um that's
interesting they would never judge you
they would never criticize you they
would only admire you they would want to
pick up the bill with you they would
think they were with a brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to you
know the first thing you have to do when
you want to do anything you have to make
a decision a lot of people brush over
this and so oh I got to make a decision
yeah no but you have to make a decision
that you're going you're not going to be
the same in any event like the mo this
moment that you're having right now on
the internet watching us in this
interview you cannot re-produce this
moment you can wish it want it walk on
fire to get it you cannot reproduce it
can't happen no matter how many
decisions you make you cannot reproduce
this one moment
the future however can be created out of
decisions like what decisions am I going
to make
to go from here to there if I don't make
that decision I don't go there
everything everything follows a decision
whether you know it or not billions of
people not Millions not hundreds of
millions billions of people are going to
get smaller as a result of This Global
reset
these are resets these are these are
redistributions of wealth whether you
believe it or not if you go back the
last couple hundred years they've been
doing this over and over again you know
there's this old thing about if you took
all the money on the planet
equally distributed to everyone it would
somehow in a very short period of Time
end up in the same hands why because
those people have specific strategies
one they're making decisions to create
wealth for themselves two massive wealth
there's not little bits of wealth they
want massive amounts of wealth okay two
they they
um they know how to Market themselves
I'm not talking about social media
marketing I'm talking about how do I
just Market myself with you or with you
right now how do I Market My Brand Apple
knows how to do it Coca-Cola General
Electric the the companies that are hot
Netflix knows how to do it you have to
learn how to do that in order to get
money to follow attention so the first
pillar is the decision to get bigger you
and your family have to make this
like you and your wife did yeah my wife
and I okay my kids my kids are on board
I got an 11 year old and 13 year old
like look our decision is to get bigger
and that requires some sacrifices number
one it's real it's possible no matter
what you hear or see or you know
uh it any level of success is real no
second thing I would tell young people
is don't focus on sports and
entertainment you know focus on business
you know I I my career will Outlast
every baseball player basketball player
rapper and performer I can go until I'm
99 years old
uh I don't need any special talent
um the next thing I would tell people is
looking best in yourself don't don't
just invest in yourself to go to college
there's so many better investments in
education like I wouldn't go to college
again personally
I would invest in myself
uh every day I spend an hour it's a two
hour studying super successful people on
YouTube if you go out on the street and
communicate and there's nobody there to
listen
did you did you actually say anything if
you send an email and it hits a junk box
and nobody saw it did did you actually
communicate
if I communicate to you and you don't
actually duplicate the communication did
the communication take place there's a
lot of sales people out there in fact I
would say most sales people majority
somewhere above three out of four
communicate
and there is no communication there's no
duplication in the communication
I know I know public speakers that get
on stage and speak to
100 people or
300 people or 30 000 people there's
really no communication
people in the back of the room never had
their attention never had their full
attention if you've ever seen a zoom
meeting or a corporate meeting obviously
and dude dude people come in the meeting
and they're all like there's this
there's this you know the delay coming
in and then and people you know can't
get anybody's attention and people are
showing up like there's no communication
going on but you think you did a meeting
and then you wonder why there's no
results guess what it's because there
was no communication even though you
spent your time and energy what does it
say
it never happened okay so if if you
communicate and it's not duplicated did
it really happen you're going home and I
said oh I'm so tired I worked so hard
really the reason you feel so tired is
because you did something and it got
nothing that actually was never done
because it wasn't duplicated as opposed
to they where you communicate clearly
and you get results and people buy from
you you go home you're like man it's the
best day of my life
you're renewed why because the
communication went both ways so that
requires you get a stage it requires you
get an audience it requires you to get
attention there's an exact science to
grabbing someone's full attention I'm
not talking about trickery and mimicry
and
uh some of these Neuroscience uh neuro
Baba pseudo Sciences yeah I'm talking
about straight up hey
do you hear what I'm saying to you
we are going to go into a massive
recession it's going to affect your
family
did I get your attention did you hear
what I said hey tell me what I just said
and then I get an audience to say yeah
dude you just said my family is going to
get spanked
and it's going to hurt
and then I said yes exactly what I said
your family's going to get beat up
and you can do something about it do you
want to
see I didn't get a clear communication
because I got attention so there's an
exact science to that even some of the
best sales people I know don't do that
well how many of you have a key or
retirement account of some sort yeah
good it's garbage it was a thing to rob
you how many of you own a home right now
let me see a hand
it was
and you put your money in there you
wanted money and you bought a house you
wanted money and then you put it in a
retirement account
you wanted money and then you gave it to
Wall Street you can't even get your
money
what'd you do man what were you thinking
or my mom I told me a house is a good
deal do you know any rich people that
say my house made me Rich
[Music]
like if I had my whole career to do over
again I would teach people about money
because basically what I've done for for
30 years you know while I was building
out these other businesses I was buying
real estate every time I'd get a surplus
of money I take the surplus of money I
push it off to the side okay let me just
show you the Simplicity of it okay first
of all I got to make more money
everybody agree everybody agree with
that dude you got to make more money
because if you don't make more money you
ain't got any money this is what Susie
Arman says don't spend your money don't
spend your money don't spend your money
don't spend your money you can't afford
it you can't afford it it was a go make
some more money
okay
right but what did she tell you don't
spend it you can't afford it the truth
is you need to make more money number
one you got to make more money or and
really in the case don't make it you
need to collect it
or get it
who's got my money
number two what do I need to do now
I need to keep the money
it's not big words
and by the way just because it's not big
words doesn't mean it's not valuable
what am I keeping the money for I didn't
say save it by the way I said keep it I
don't need you to save money there is no
money made by Saving today how many of
you know about compound interest
you're like compound interest is the
Holy Grail no no not today it didn't
there is no compound if you're making
point zero four percent at the bank
today's national uh Friday's average
savings rate in America was 0.12
percent
that ain't 12 percent that's point one
two percent that's not 1.2 percent
that's 12 tenths of one percent it take
you 80 years
to make ten percent of your money
okay my mom was earning 10 or 12 percent
20 years ago she was earning 10 to 12
percent in the bank so every seven years
that money doubled you know the rule of
seven
the seven it was a calculator right if
you earn 10 on your money every seven
years it would roll over and double
okay do this I think this is like I
don't know 144 years to double money
three trillion dollars sitting in Banks
how many of you have a partner you have
a partner in business
good how many of you do not have a
partner in business let me see your hand
okay yeah you do it's the bank
you took your money and you trusted a
bank would it
what does the bank do
they think the paper's so useless they
get rid of it
[Music]
you can't get your money back how many
saw the video I did where I tried to get
a million dollars in cash for my bank
somebody said Grant you can't get your
money I said what do you mean man got me
all freaked out stopped my whole day
what you mean I can't get my money man I
saw it on my account man and then maybe
I hung up with the phone with him I'm
like I wonder if I can get my money I
don't know
the things that I invest in today I
promise you will be around longer than
Facebook
listen to what I'm telling you right now
okay in your lifetime there might not be
a Facebook this phone right here how
many believe this phone this phone will
cease to exist in the next 20 years
ain't no way this phone's going to be
around 20 years from now
okay the things I invest in
will outlive this phone we'll outlive
Apple computer that's the only thing I
go out every day this is how I think
about money I'm running every day for
money I'm going I'm busting my ass man
I'm busting my ass every day I'm busting
my ass I I you know I'm busting my
trying to fill up the refrigerator take
care of the kids get good education for
them fuel the plane up put fuel in the
plane fly the plane take care of the
plane watch the plane invest in my
business right this is what I'm doing
all day long you know and then and then
what I'm trying to do really is I'm
trying to I'm trying to
put this money to use at some point okay
operate with what's called what I call
is a 40 point I'm looking for 40 percent
to save on my income whatever it takes
how much money do I need to make so that
I have 40 percent
that I can take over here and shove a
big giant piece of cake into a deal
in a room like sales you're like I just
love
you love it okay stay away from this man
keep your kids away from it stay away
from him okay
it's a whack job right here okay anybody
that likes sales he only likes it
because he's good at it
because there was a time when he didn't
like it nobody naturally likes
approaching a person
presenting a product
asking them to buy it like everybody
gets uncomfortable right
so so one thing one trick that I thought
that that was the whole trick in
business like I got to go out and sell
something that's not the trick you need
to build a business and everybody in
here's the business she is a business
her job is to get attention for her
brand discover her brand clarify her
brand yeah that's my brand don't be
stealing on my brand but she could she
could she could ride she could ride
she's collaborating with me when she
does that she is collaborating with the
brand we we invited you here so we could
collaborate with you
how many of you went to our conference
here in Miami
okay oh a few of you okay
it's 35 000 people there
35 000. I have more people in Marlin
stadium
than the Marlins can put in their
Stadium
the Marlins and the Dolphins
that just shows you how important
success is
right some of you were going to go to
the game this Sunday you're like I ain't
going hey I wouldn't go here much less
New York right so because nobody wants
to be around losers
like bottom line so you got to get
yourselves it's easy to talk about the
Dolphins right okay but but you got to
get yourself in a position where you win
it folks
you know I remember there was a time in
my life where I I didn't want to be
around me
I knew I had this much potential and I
was delivering like right here I I
didn't like me I hated me
same thing when I started having a
business my business had three or four
employees
I didn't like that about me because I
knew I should have more employees earn
some power earn the right to have some
power some responsibility keep the power
okay and save and multiply it you want
you want to multiply you don't want to
hoard it it's not about keeping it to
keep it for yourself it's about how do I
now multiply this is what your mom and
dad said this is what my mom and dad
didn't know they knew how to keep it
they did not know how to multiply stuff
okay that's why with most of your if I'm
right about you in this audience just
from looking at you judging you a little
bit is you were probably brought up the
way I was eat all your food
how many were taught that three times a
day eat it all eat it all eat it all if
you didn't eat it all put it in the
refrigerator you're like look I didn't
want it hot I'm not going to want it
tomorrow
I don't want this this done I don't know
shave it save it somebody's somewhere
starving somebody somewhere and I'm like
dude like like you guys go back to your
refrigerator tonight see if you're not
affected by this open your refrigerator
and look in and see how much
that you
see how much stuff
from Jared see how much stuff that
you're saving that you don't want
that you don't want to eat the only
reason you're saving stuff you don't
want is because you're worried about
earning more period Then I want you to
walk to your closet just a little
exercise go to your closet open your
closet I want you to look at shoes pants
slacks jackets that you haven't worn in
years
probably don't even fit you but you
refuse to throw them away
I gotta save it
I gotta save it I got to save it because
you're worried about earning money
enough money to pay for more stuff
because you know in your heart of hearts
you know that mechanism for you is
broken
you have to fix this you have a
responsibility to fix it so you can do
nothing tonight
okay it will not get better you can go
do it on your own
most of you look like you've had enough
time how old are you sir
he's had enough time at 41. dude if you
ain't fixed it in 41 uh whatever data
you have
has got you in that chair and that
that's that's what I know about myself I
have to change for me to change I have
to change and for the for the most part
that doesn't mean I need to do more it
means I need new information I am an
extremely hard individual okay I know
what it takes to be in the position I'm
in it is not easy okay I have paid
attention for 30 years to everything
when it comes in and when it goes out
and where it goes and whether or not
this energy that came in or the energy I
put out hey does it actually pay me so
that I can produce something in the
future okay anybody anybody can have
this much success in life
to string it together for 32 years never
have a bankruptcy never not pay a debt
never ever ever okay walk away from
something I didn't know it is very very
difficult
going out knocking on the door making
some money getting a sale great winning
of course in a case in court great okay
getting a degree to college good you can
do that okay anybody can do all that
stuff to stream together 30 years
and be able to survive recessions okay I
am an extremely intelligent person when
it comes to money okay we're the most
resilient
people on the planet I mean except for
maybe persons
I mean really persons are unbelievable
people okay okay in the Romans the
Romans were pretty successful okay but
but you notice if you look at those
civilizations man Persian wrote look
there was a time when they had
everything they had it all and they lost
it because they started making mistakes
they started thinking oh well we'll go
on forever we don't have to be diligent
we don't have to pay attention we don't
have to do the right things okay you
were on a ship
you're on the same ship I'm on okay I
own the ship but guess what it won't
matter it won't matter when the shift go
ship goes through rough orders hey your
stomach's gonna feel the same as mine
I'm not the only one that is scared in
these Waters I just know I ain't getting
off the ship
for you you actually could say and I'm
gonna get off I can't get off you
understand this is my show
okay my ship's gonna finish this trip I
did 35 years of this I guarantee you I
will die on that ship okay and I will
find other places to go adventure and
other places to have victories and other
civilizations to meet okay this is my
trip and if you want to be on it with me
for the whole ride you can be you can
get off anytime you want to probably
half of you will at some point get off
say I'm done here I got that man I will
pull into Port one day we'll drop the
what's that thing we'll drop the anchor
well hopefully you don't get off on the
gang Walk The Gang walk means we push
you off
hopefully you wait till we get to Port
and then you get off and then you walk
off into the village and you get some
some woman in the village pregnant and
you settle down there and you become uh
be cool
okay can you imagine back in that time
hey new place let's go visit the people
hey are we going to be here in the
future well one thousand percent are we
going to do another 10 extra conference
guaranteed
okay I mean if I'm not going to do
another one of those I'm not doing any
I'm like I'm done I need to go home get
on a ship and travel around and and not
come back to work anymore are we going
to do are you going to buy more real
estate oh for 100 sure
so you're not going to stop this brand
and and the the the desire people have
and my mission is to help people
so and I cannot do this by myself every
one of you is needed okay but I need you
I need you right now to lean into this
thing
your job depends on what you do every
day your job depends on
okay not not your job with me your job
period on this planet
depends on how much you take your
shoulder and put it against a will and
push and get a product a product
okay for us this products are people
know about Grant Cardone people know
about our webinars people know about our
opportunities people know about our
books I need you to do more than your
job I'm already paying you to do your
job
okay
you're not going to get a bonus if you
don't do more than your job I'm just
telling you
I will not get a bonus if I don't do
more than my job
Kevin Hart will not get a bonus if he
don't finish that movie
if the tickets don't sell Kevin Hart
will not get the bonus you have the MLB
baseball players for the Marlins they do
not get paid this year if there is no
season you understand that
they don't like oh get my check anyway
you didn't play bro
okay if I get hurt in the NFL and I
don't play I don't get paid that's the
real world
so when I get the when I hear the
numbers in the morning sometimes you
guys don't see me there because when I
hear we got a hundred licensees I'm like
God damn we should have ten thousand and
everybody in this room should have sold
one and got a commission on it
so again if you don't like if you're in
shipping Sherry told me somebody in
shipping them like why is that person in
shipping when's that person how can that
person live on 16 an hour
or twenty dollars an hour we took them
down from 20. how can you live on twenty
dollars an hour
in Miami
okay I'm not going to pay any more for
the position
how can you make sense of it I don't I
don't understand that like
there's all this other stuff we have to
sell man everybody every time I meet
somebody coming to my boot camp coming
to my webinar you coming you got my book
you got this program you got a wristband
okay how about a t-shirt
like like every time I talk to somebody
I'm like once you grab one of my things
because I know that drives a little bit
of Exchange
once he gives me money he has a
relationship with me
the moment he gives me money we actually
complete the relationship it is only
then okay you guys that are on Natalie's
team you can call and talk to these
people and help them as much as you want
you're not actually having a
relationship when you do this help
when they exchange back with you you
complete the health cycle okay they have
to give you something for the help
otherwise it's a handout
and nobody wants to handle
it except people that have given up
and lost self-respect of themselves
nobody wants a handout they want a
little hey come on you know but nobody
they'll resent me if I keep giving them
a handgun so remember when they say hey
I want something great make sure they
give you something back
okay so so that we can complete that
relationship or start one and we can
start actually doing business with one
another what is a mindset or belief that
you have
that you feel most of the time people
disagree with you on
well I think a lot
positive person and I'm not okay this
has nothing to do with positivity or
motivation
uh I I'm not I'm not like
you know Mr beat my chest I'm excited
and I'm gonna I'm gonna see myself
through this because I'm going to will
myself through it now I'm not going to
do that like I'm going to do something
what I'm going to do is do something I'm
going to make a call I'm going to send
out an email I'm going to follow that up
I'm going to build a team that can do
the same thing like I'm going to win on
action
and it doesn't mean it's it doesn't mean
I'm going to outwork you
I'm going to out result you
so and I'm not trying to out result you
by the way I'm just like I need to I
need to get results in the marketplace
so I remember uh Gary vaynerchuk was in
my studio once and he was telling me
he's like I'll outwork you I'm like bro
you I mean we just met it you don't know
me I don't know you I don't know what
your work ethic is I don't know what you
do and there's no way you can know
whether you outwork me or not and by the
way it doesn't even matter
what matters is do we get results
and so what we've been successful with
this whole 10x thing is about hey I am
going to set a Target
10 times higher than what I need for
myself and I'm going to do whatever I
have to do between now and the
attainment of that Target to to get that
that is not a Minds that it is a
decision
but it's not some positivity thing or
enthusiasm like I think people mistake
that I think that's that's to answer
your question I'm talking to an audience
that wants to get rich just trying to
really like make something make
something big yeah like become like
Robert Smith Rich you know he's the
wealthiest black man in America or Don
peoples my friend who's worth a couple
billion dollars in playing in the real
estate game or you know like I I want to
get to the top of the food chain where I
get to start making rules he who has the
goal makes the rule and so I don't want
a little money I don't want a retirement
account I don't want my house paid for I
don't care about any of that stuff I
want to get rich I want to create
tremendous amounts of wealth for for the
people that that my community for the
people it started off for my handful
like me my wife my kids and then once
I'm like okay I can help more than that
I can help I can
I don't mean my neighborhood
people in my neighborhood can be helped
right okay they can be helped they need
help and by the way where I live right
down the street they just don't know
they need help they're rich but they're
not wealthy they're not helping anybody
else dude they're just helping
themselves it's freaking terrible it's a
myth it's a life of poverty to have your
house paid for it's a mental poverty
like oh I got my house paid for I got my
two cars my kids are going to private
schools and I'm miserable because
there's no purpose uh like I'm helping
millions of people around the world what
are you gonna do what are you going to
do on a daily basis you got to keep
yourself busy you got to figure out some
kind of way to keep yourself busy
they're going to share with you my
team's going to share with you a little
schedule I use I'll be talking about
goal setting set goals how to achieve
goals how to keep your calendar full
because if your calendar is not full and
you said okay I'ma quit doing dumb stuff
and I'm gonna I'm gonna quit hanging
around these idiots
um well the truth is you got nothing to
do and you're going to sit around and
boredom's going to get you and you're
going to go back and you're going to
start doing the same you were we're the
same people you were doing it with it
wasn't until I filled up my calendar
with activities
and then got good at those activities
that my life actually changed and the
last thing was I had I needed to start
adding some people that could change my
life so the last three things is you got
to get better at something keep your
activities full when you're winning when
you're doing things you're good at you
will want to do it a lot you will not
burn out on things you're doing well and
the other thing is you've got to get
around the right people why do I insist
that apartments are the greatest
investment of the group why should you
focus here for your initial foray into
real estate investing in short it's
because Apartments passed a number of
tests that are vital to you not having
to worry about whether or not you're
going to make money in a deal okay
you're here to win you're here to make
money I'm all in an apartment for key
reasons first apartments or real assets
when you own apartments and you own real
tangible assets you benefit from a
number of things one you benefit from
appreciation going forward if you picked
a good location cash flow right right
now while you sit and wait and it's more
expensive in the future going forward to
build these apartments than it was to
buy them number two apartments produce
positive cash flow at least they should
if you bought it right if you got the
right debt on it and if you pick the
right property Apartments produce
positive cash flow which is the Holy
Grail of finance a concept that very few
people ever get right almost as
importantly as inflation same thing with
cash flow you're underestimating the
value of positive cash flow when you
pick a property it is cash flow that
gives it value going forward because one
you get to keep it long term and two it
gives you security when you go to sleep
at night now that brings me to number
three this is called the multiplier
effect when rents rise if they do in
your Market apartment values increase if
you're ready to take the next step and
start investing in real estate like a
total Pro you have to start with the big
why why a particular class of asset
you're very Scrappy and so it's like do
you ever worry like calling out the
black rocks and these guys I mean you're
basically you know
stand there
and I'm like well it's not a good thing
to do if you're going to stay small
but if you have what they want they'll
they'll forgive you
so what what we're doing is we're very
strategic about collecting
the kind of assets that they are forced
to eat okay they they don't they know no
matter how big and powerful you get you
still have Achilles seals
right your your your your your business
plan becomes your
business plan
you know it becomes the thing that like
if I know your business plan then
I can participate in your business plan
so I can become a necessary evil to the
BlackRock or you know maybe they can buy
you someday maybe or maybe
maybe yeah maybe we do the flippy dippy
and I make my big move bro look don't
think that these big giants can't fall
they have fallen like all you got to do
is go back hundreds of years man just
assume that 40 million people are going
to be put out of work dude I would act
like I'm gonna 40 million people gonna
be put out of work at one weekend that's
what I would go into January saying the
entire world is going to shut down uh
you're not going to be able to get
anything you won't be able to get
anybody on the phone you won't be able
to use your internet like just go
violent paranoid yeah and and that way
you're going to be right
because even if none of that happens
you're gonna You're Gonna Act
appropriately that's right which is how
people should act all the time that's
how I act all the time I'm always acting
like like you're broke nope I'm always
broke yeah but I'm always broke yeah so
I like that a lot you know because no
matter how much success I achieve today
no matter what happens today I'm gonna
wake up Saturday morning
and I'll be like I'm starting over from
zero again right I'm not starting from
where I'm where yesterday in it I'm
starting from zero that's right and so I
keep accumulating like that I don't mean
money I mean customer success and that
becomes the unbreakable business that we
talk about
I was on a boat a 200 foot yacht in in
south of France and I said man when you
guys are coming through storms 30 and 40
foot ways like he's like man we don't
worry about the ship we worry about the
crew crew breaks before the ship does
so that's what's going to happen in
recession your crew's gonna break up
loyal people are going to blow off
people are going to quit jobs that
should not quit jobs you're not getting
that to fire people they're just gonna
quit like like people go Looney Tunes
okay because there's bad news everywhere
so first thing is hey set a new Target
for 2023 and it's going to be a big
Target it's gonna be giant something
that terrifies you second day we're
going to handle marketing how much
marketing would you have to do to tell a
story
because you're going to be able to buy
ads for a fraction
like we're we're gonna hit we're going
to start pounding Twitter right now
because I know dot uh ad dollars are
moving away from Elon right now so I'll
go in and say you know I'll be I'll be a
huckleberry
okay so we're looking for opportunities
right but that follows that decision
making we want to 10x to our business I
do 150 million dollars a year I want to
do I'm going to figure out how to do a
billion five a year in sales I have to
10x mate
so I need a strategy right Marketing
sales then it's gonna be like how big a
sales team do I need to start Gathering
these sales to monetize and this this
activity we're going to make I need
other communities I need other languages
for me to do a billion dollars I cannot
do it on only English-speaking people
you need you you need like you said you
need people that don't look like it
Mandarin Hispanic kids
snapchatters tick talkers collaboration
you get me an audience that I don't have
like like that's what that's what has to
happen y'all got to stay broke man cash
is garbage you don't need money you
don't need cash cash is trash your mommy
and daddy didn't know this cash is
garbage it is trash take it out use it
it is worthless until it is put to work
okay listen to me money is worthless
until it is put to work
money is useless until it is used
it's a piece of paper
okay it's got God on it look how they
treat this let's put God on there man
okay we'll put a we'll put Ben Franklin
it wasn't God's idea to have his his
name on a piece of paper everybody agree
with that that's that's a pitch
come on man put Ben Franklin on this
right he's a president
okay like he ain't he ain't my president
he did
and then we act like a sacred and I got
to keep it and protect it and now it's
mine this is what this is what uh
Brandon was doing this morning we're
talking about currency if you look at
the word it comes from current current
flows it has to be in circulation
right it's it's it's plentiful it's a
piece of paper it's only valuable when I
take it out of my pocket get it out of
the system and put it to work
if I give it to the bank if I call up
Wells Fargo today and say Here's a
hundred dollars what are they gonna do
with it
they're going to convert it instantly
converted into digits and then they will
send it out nine times
almost 10x
hey you guys keep asking me what enough
money is how many times I got to tell
you first of all if you're asking a
question you don't have enough money
number two enough money by definition at
least my definition would be you can
take care of everyone you love
everyone's all the people your sister
that you forgot about your aunt that
took care of you when you were growing
up maybe a school teacher that helped
you out a bunch is struggling now but
you can help your two kids your wife or
husband
and your parents and beyond that you
know what I'm saying you can reach deep
start helping all the people you love
that would be enough money and still
take care of yourself by the way I know
some of you out there taking care of
everybody else but you don't take care
of yourself so you'd have to be able to
take care of everybody you love all the
people you forgot that you love and the
people that can't take care of
themselves the guy on the street corner
that you're like dude I feel sorry for
this guy I want to help him out you can
take care of all those people and
yourself and I'm not done
okay
when you expire and you're done your
history you can't work anymore can't
produce anymore you're you're expired
you would steal you had enough money to
still take care of the people you love
the things you love the Charities you
love the causes that you believe in
yeah that's what would be enough money
and still not be out by the way
you would have abundance in every way
you would have Wealth Beyond anything
that's destructible
it would last forever and you could
literally change the world
with the money that you produce because
you were committed
you were charitable
you cared enough to go big enough
a lot of you guys man y'all just don't
care about enough people that's why you
think so small
it's not about the cars and the shades
and the clothes and the watches yeah all
those things are cool and everything but
the real game
is can you create enough wealth
continue
and you can by the way it's possible for
anyone to do if you dream big enough
it's not possible if you don't make this
big
but if you did think this big
you could think this big if you got
around other people that thought this
big
they'd encourage you to think big and
really live into your full potential
you could create create you could
you couldn't present starting from zero
still create enough wealth to take care
of you all the people you love all the
people you forgot that you love and
even when you're done you could keep
taking care of people how to be a
billionaire I want to be a billionaire I
want to be a billionaire you know that's
all man [__] I was summing that song I'm
like I want to be a billionaire and a
lady came up to me after this meeting I
did this morning in Los Angeles she says
I just want to be a millionaire I'm like
you already are a millionaire she's like
what do you mean I'm like look
everybody's a millionaire or something
everybody is a millionaire come on how
many times have you had gas at least a
million times in your lifetime right how
many times have you took a breath of air
at least a million times how many times
has your heart beat it your heart beat
it that's not even a word but how many
times does that happen right at least a
million times see most people are
millionaires in many things they're just
not like looking at what they're a
millionaire at being a millionaire is
not that difficult I'm telling you it's
not that difficult look how many people
do you know that are millionaires and
excuses millionaires in being late
millionaires in not making things work
how about a millionaire at failing how
about a millionaire at dreams see how
about a millionaire thoughts look if you
can be a millionaire that easily in so
many different areas once you just put
your focus down and say hey now I'm
going to be a millionaire at money
because that's what it is it's about
Focus what are you focused on excuses
reasons Alibis justifications being late
eating too much chocolate you think you
hadn't had a million pieces of chocolate
in your lifetime probably how have you
overeaten a million times do you have a
million calories of consumption in your
lifetime sure a million breaths of air
million heartbeats you're a millionaire
already just change the way you're
thinking about it hey now I want to Be a
Millionaire on money now I want to now I
want to create enough wealth for myself
and my family so I can actually take
care of them folks that's not a bad
thing oh and by the way you guys that
say oh money won't make you happy look
you're just a millionaire excuses you're
a millionaire at little quotes that mean
nothing and go nowhere what are you
going to be a Millionaire on I got my
shades on this morning John you know why
why because my future's so bright
I tried to go without him this morning
but it was like I was being Blinded By
by what was in front of me by the
possibility by the potential of the
potential you know I was I was thinking
this morning John
I was thinking this morning on a serious
note somebody asked me last night hey
what drives you
and uh
I'm like yeah what does drive me for a
moment I didn't have an answer it kind
of threw me off a little bit I mean I
know the answer it threw me off a little
bit because I'm like what is driving me
now
you know it's different than what was
driving me when I was busted up
and
and then I looked at it I looked at it
and I said oh wow you know what's been
driving me the whole time is the just
the little improvements the possibility
of improvement you know which is really
what potential is
doesn't matter how big your potential is
or because because the true potential of
the individual I don't think is revealed
without success like you got to have
little successes
to get a little peek of what you can do
I don't think any others actually know
what we can do
and so when you're 25 years old I was 25
I was broke had no money didn't have any
friends my family didn't believe in me
I had no money
when I went from no money in my pocket I
had 50 bucks all of a sudden I was like
wow and by the way I earned that 50
nobody gave it to me I didn't steal it I
didn't rip anybody off I earned it
I was like wow it was a big deal that 50
bucks was a big big deal then when I
learned how to consistently do that and
started discipline myself to not waste
the money blow it on dumb stuff not end
up with a hangover for 50 bucks I know a
lot of people make 50 bucks and end up
with a hangover
and that's all they end up with not even
a memory
and and and then I did 500 and then I
did a thousand and then all of a sudden
I started oh wow man maybe this money
thing is important
because it started making me feel a
little bit better about myself and then
the next thing you know I'm going I'm
having meetings with
other people that are thinking about
success and my network is changing a
little bit and now the next thing I know
is my health has changed a little bit
and my sense of self is changing it was
the attainment of the potential in
little increments so for the last 30
years basically what I've done is work
in increments little tiny improvements
every day
but this is the most important thing
that I found out
if you show up
every day and work on the little
improvements what will happen is along
the way you hear people talk about
setbacks and and and and bad things
happen to them but if you if you keep
showing up every day I promise you in
addition to some setbacks they're going
to come
you're also going to see spikes
and surges
little pops upward just like I said back
but if you're showing up every day with
the right attitude right people right
surroundings reading the right books
getting the right material looking for
little improvements what will happen is
you'll get the spikes and the spurts in
fact you'll get more of those and you
will setbacks and it's the spikes and
the spurts it's that boom that big
growth
even children get this little little
kids have spikes and spurts of growth
okay this is what reveals
the real potential this is what keeps
people really excited about possibility
and what you can do
and that's what drives me today
okay look the increments are great today
but I'm really looking for those spikes
I'm looking for those those those surges
of growth financially
Network people connections ideas
I hope you go find those spikes and
spurts but you're not going to get them
you're not going to get a surge without
the daily increments
and that's what drives me today because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible John Assaraf motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there setting goals is an
intellectual and imagine exercise that
your conscious brain right I'm going to
show you one of the little brains today
from the city hall Mass your conscious
brain